foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
a storm is brewing
oh my goodness there are no more checks
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm
oh we missed it oh yeah oh my goodness
for some this is familiar ground oh my
gosh
oh my gosh oh my God what a tactic
where's the mate though I don't know but
it's gotta be there oh my God
the
moves will be fast
starting to see Bishop C7 oh my God the
stakes will be high
oh my gosh the 2022 speed Chess
Championship is now
passenger speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship I'm your host Robert Hess
alongside me Grandmaster Daniel the
Prophet narodisky Dania with an epic
semi-final yesterday today we have
another epic one in store
we do indeed Robert I feel like after
Magnus Carlson's last match against
Fabiano Caron we've all been looking at
our watches and waiting with baited
breath when is this next MC match going
to happen well here we are we didn't
have to wait very long we had a couple
matches in the meantime to tide us over
well we have MC vs mvl today with a lot
at stake because there's quite a bit of
prize money you make it known every
single time that number goes up from two
to four this time six thousand dollars
plus an additional six thousand dollars
a split of that based on win percentage
but I think most importantly to these
players a world champion and a world
Blitz Champion the winner moves the
champion match to face hikar Nakamura
listen normally I emphasize that the
prizes are generous and they are and it
matters to the players but in this
particular case anytime Magnus Carlsen
enters the conversation for his opponent
there's only one motivator and that is
to beat Magnus Carlson across a
three-hour imagine for Magnus Carlson
well it's the opposite to assert his
dominance yet again as he's been doing
time and again in the SEC 2022. I
thought you're gonna say it's the
opposite it's to not beat Magnus Carlson
because sometimes it feels like the only
way for mags to lose is for maggots to
beat himself but either way let's take a
look at the bracket because we do have
one finalist in Hikaru Nakamura but down
to the other side of the bracket Magnus
has been dominant but MPL has been no
slouch either
hey it's kind of been a slow she hasn't
beaten anybody all that good he's only
beaten a world champion Contender and
then he beat the winner of the cgc uh by
four points mvl has been an absolute
Beast make no mistake and Magnus
Carlson's performances they have a way
of overshadowing the path that others
have taken so mvl has been nothing short
of a hero he has had arguably the most
impressive run thus far behind Magnus
Carlson but he's gonna have to put in a
little bit of extra and he's gonna have
to show a lot of nasty if he wants to
defeat the world champion today no it's
true when Magus Carlson plays he's Clark
Kent he's Superman but mvl might just be
the Kryptonite as we dive into today's
matchup between Magnus Carlson the world
champion and Maxine versus the world
Blitz champion Daniel same age Blitz
rating the nod goes to Magnus Carlsen
but the head to head goes mvl's way
it does Magnus looking mighty smog in
that photo he's like I the match has
already been decided mvl looking and not
not quite not quite yet you know maybe
this will be close match but mvo one of
the only players perhaps the only player
to lead Magnus Carlson across a wide
sample size we're not talking here
Robert about a two game match or a
one-game fluke anything can happen in
one Blitz game they played well over 40
Blitz Games and mvl has been neck and
neck against Magnus there always seems
to be that one player across all sports
who has the world champions number I'm
pretty sure MBL does have his actual
number but he also has had his number
historically over the board
no it's for sure the case and mvl he
beat him in that previous SEC matchup
it's one of the major story lines of
today's event can Magnus get that
revenge and Maxi also beat Magnus in the
final round of the 2021 World boots
Championship which Maxine won in that
tiebreak match he is the world champion
based on that but as we look at this
graphic here Dania mvl the only player
to defeat Magnus you know vengeance is
on his brain oh it absolutely is and
it's not just on his brain what's on his
brain is he wants to repeat the
performance against Fabiano Caron and he
doesn't want to beat mvl 18 to 17 and
say hey hey I've gotten my revenge he
wants to crush MBL and run him out of
the gym because that's been the spirit
Magnus Carlson has shown thus far and
let me tell you Magnus is most certainly
aware of their head-to-head score right
they're all Chill on the surface when
you interview them they say they don't
really care they were looking at the
scores oh I'm sure Magnus is aware of
their head-to-head Blitz score oh I
believe that and he wants that Revenge
but chess in objective game you need to
remain composed but either way 16
players started in this field only three
remain we have one finalist nicario
Nakamura two semifinals in Maxine vasila
Grove and Magnus Carlsen remaining we'll
see who moves on but the scores are
across three time patrols it's a format
we know and love and Donna if we do get
down to Armageddon if everything is tied
get into the match and we saw their
clothes Head to Head who gets the nod
from you Robert stop asking me questions
I'm drinking coffee I'm trying to enjoy
this match okay I would say I would go
in my classic advice which is that if
you're the underdog you want to shorten
this match you want to get it tied going
into the bullet and if you offered mvl
and Armageddon right now just eliminate
the whole three hour match go straight
into the arm again he would agree with
open arms because like I said the role
of coincidence the role of Randomness it
increases greatly the shorter the match
becomes so if things get down to a four
game one plus one match I'm gonna say
it's a total 50 50 affair here as it
stands right now in over the course of a
three-hour match and we'll get to that
in a moment I'm still going with the
world champion it's a really good point
you want to remain neck and neck because
in small samples then the underdog has a
better chance but it's a long match so
let's talk about the format remind
everybody that this is played across
three type patrols we start with an hour
and a half of five minute plus one
second increment we then get to a full
hour of three minute plus one second and
last but certain not least we got 30
minutes of bullet chess one minute plus
one second increment so Dania you're
very familiar with these players you've
played them many times who has the
favorite in each time segment yeah
that's a great question I'm not going to
answer this exactly well I am I think MC
is the favorite in the five plus one
Magnus Carlson is the favorite in the
three plus one and Magnus is the
favorite in the OnePlus One so on paper
he's the favorite in all three segments
and unfortunately that means I'm
agreeing with smarter chess but again
we'll get to that in a moment but mvl he
has to get off to a quick start even
against kukesh Magnus played a
self-professed terrible match when she
won 23-7 against the 2700 plus GM Magnus
lost the second five minute game but
after that he was nowhere to be seen he
was dashing Off to the Races he was
winning games and these top players they
don't fall asleep they don't take any
games as warm-up games they go straight
for the throat from the beginning and
mvl he's gonna have to match that
intensity he's obviously gonna have to
match the speed and he's gonna have to
match magnus's tactical sharpness both
early and late in this match and he's
gonna have to find a way to score
Victory five minutes could not do that
but according to Smart chest predictions
this match should remain relatively
close Magnus Carlson has a two-point
lead in the five plus one then a one
point separation in both the three and
the OnePlus One side patrols 1612
predicted score and done it 68 is smart
chess's nod in favor of Magnus Carlsen I
would think 75 80 what about you
yeah it's a weird situation because
again mvl does have the plus record in
their head-to-head Blitz Games but I
think we all understand that that
doesn't necessarily mean he's the
favorite in this match I think given
magnus's recent form given mbl's small
dose of rust he's a little bit on the
rusty side especially compared to Magnus
I would agree that 68 if anything is a
bit of an understatement I would go with
something like 75 or 80 in the world
champions favor
well that is a big number either way we
are giving the nod as the pre-match
favorite to Magnus Carlsen and the
community got involved they submitted
their brackets over 15 000 people did
just that and of those six percent that
predict this matchup 84 seed Magnus
Carlson going through so the community
the chat they agree with us
damn girl 84 people really uh not going
on a limb here people don't really know
how Las Vegas odds work you're supposed
to go with the underdog but I see you
186 of you go with the Frenchman with
three names he is very much capable he
has shown a time and time again and he's
got that grittiness Robert he's got that
sharpness in his style that I think
might just allow him to get under
magnus's skin he's also shown a diverse
repertoire something we're not
accustomed to from Maxine versilograph
that will give him increased chances and
well only five people have a chance to
fill out that perfect bracket we started
with over 15
000 people and when we set you out on
this Quest and heading into today's
match with Magnus and mvl there are 26
perfect brackets still intact however
due to tie Breakers there are only five
perfect brackets still eligible to win a
ten thousand dollar first place prize
and Daniel I'll let you do honors of
reading off those names that we see on
screen in front of us right we got a
couple ones that are easy to pronounce
and a few that I might butcher we got
grave dangerer who predicts Magnus and
Magnus ice 07 V shawl 06 okay this is
the tough one
predicting big surprise there MBL who
would have thought and winner winner
chicken dinner I haven't heard that
phrase in a while predicting mvl as the
semi number two pick and then Hikaru as
the champion some interesting choices
there he thinks mvl is going to defeat
Magnus
seat belts fasten ladies and gentlemen
only three of these brackets or two of
these brackets are going to remain
perfect after this match I think I did
the math correctly my speed belt is
certainly fast fascinated I'm thankful
for you because that's why I want you to
read them out that French name I didn't
want to butcher it I don't want all of
Maxim's French fans after me so Donya
those five uh contestants they still
have a shot at ten thousand dollars for
the first place prize at the start of
championships Sunday we may have fewer
and any wrenches money up for grabs oh
my God this is such an exciting moment
this is the best mode this is right
before you started opening your birthday
gifts right or you open a jar of peanut
butter and it's like all perfect the
match hasn't started yet we got three
hours at least of entertainment in front
of us and we are by now accustomed to
the players surroundings and to Magnus
Carlson state of relaxation Robert as
the match kicks off he's always leaning
back yeah I don't really care mode and
then before you know it he's up 10 10-3
did Mexico get a haircut by the way his
eyes are closed he's calming himself
meditating I think he's looking fresh
for this fight and is that a French
you know football kit is he you know
channeling his country
yeah but where is snacks that's the
bigger question the magic kicks off I
don't think he's capable of flank
through an opening without some snacks
the first surprise on move three Knight
b2d2 looks odd because your Bishop on C1
is blocking his place but there we see
it Magnus was B3 it should be two
fianchettos he'll eventually break open
with a move like C4
and he
barely goes He car remote hikara likes
to play this with a one Knight F3 move
order but a very tame opening choice I
am the by Magnus Carlson MBL responding
another big surprise with a grunfeld
setup I mean who would have thought well
it might be a bit surprising just
because Maxime he was playing dodgeball
in that match against Wesley so he was
changing his openings throughout he's
made himself hard to pin down and here
Maxine plays Bishop F5 and then Max
takes his big think and plays Bishop E2
you may say 20 seconds not a big thing
but I think it indicates that this is
not preparation anymore this is Magnus
just playing and opening for the sake of
getting into novel territory and I think
that was magnus's strategy in the early
going of this match we will see if this
leads to success we'll see if he keeps
repeating this but I think he's
basically saying I want to chill out I
want to start with a couple of slow
games positional Affairs I don't want to
enter any immediate theoretical disputes
against mvl but we have seen both of
these players you just referenced that
in mbl's case Magnus Carlson has shown a
willingness to change his openings as
the match goes along as well both of
these players especially Magnus having
just a vast repertoire and vast
understanding of different types of
positions good call c2c4 by the world
champion and typically we see the move
C7 to C6 played here just to keep the
pawn structure intact black does not
want to take on C4 that gives white the
massive Center and better control of the
E4 Square so right now that pawn on D5
is very important so I think that C6 or
as you're pointing out C5 is an option
to strike back in the center and C5 is
the more grun-filled-esque move but I
think it fails concretely c5c takes D5
and you can't recapture because of E4
with a fork on the minor pieces and whoa
white Robert has his Sage advice DC4 the
eval bar wasn't happy either I think
we're in the same camp here I weird
Choice by MBL I think it means he wants
to strike with C5 though I think he
wants to play more ambitiously more
actively with his pieces but you are
giving white to Center and after Knight
takes for if you play C5 I believe white
can just push that pawn up to D5 and so
White's claiming I have an extra
opponent Center a d and an E Pawn and
things are looking good but no Magnus
says I'm just gonna Castle no D5 right
now and he just keeps the tension and I
think MBL has the shorter end of the
stick here and in part that's because of
the placement of the F5 Bishop now you
might say well that Bishop looks like
it's perfectly developable if you think
about it after C takes D4 Knight takes
D4 the bishop starts getting harassed it
starts getting kicked around the board
and it doesn't have a way back because
of the Knight on D7 so black is just a
little bit cramped here in the early
going and these are the kinds of
positions where Magnus just activates
Superman mode yeah this feels like I'm
watching nihal sardon Once Again the
opening doesn't look like anything
that's special but you're inducing a
weakness like the move B5 a good move in
this position from Maxine Russia but in
the long term you have so many weak
squares you're pointing Knight C4 to E5
that C6 square is often very juicy for a
knight to jump into
and you could carve the C4 Square back
out for yourself you could drop the
Knight back to D2 and then meet A6 with
a very typical shot a2a4 now in that
position black can't even push before
because he loses the A6 Pawn but the
larger positional aim of the move A4 is
to get yourself that C4 Square yet again
so Robert it isn't just about occupying
a space Advantage when you push your
pawns you're leaving weaknesses in your
wake and Max understands this is a big
decision do I jump forward with the
Knight and offer some trades or as done
is just highlighting Knight back to D2
it allows Queen to B6 Pawn to A6 black
it maintains control over there on the
queen side gets active so he chooses
Knight to E5 and A6 played anyway but
done it your A4 move is very tempting
and I would not be surprised if Magnus
takes on C5 here because if the Black
Knight takes back then there's also
Knight into D4 a movie you mentioned
earlier hitting the bishop 105 going for
the C6 Square I feel like there's some
strategic problems that black is going
to find difficult to solve for sure and
this is kind of 0.7 mode right Magnus
loves positions with this kind of
evaluation
struggling yesterday to convert these
types of small advantages but something
tells me Magnus is going to play a
little bit differently there's that A4
move and more problems logistically
Robert for MBL if he brings his Queen up
to B6 which I think he very well might
there's ideas connected to taking on C5
and then sticking a bishop on D4 and
before you know it all of your minor and
heavy pieces on the queen side get
clustered up and White's gonna have all
sorts of threats there this is already
getting pretty unpleasant for black it
certainly is and there's also a universe
where white could consider pushing the
opponent D5 I mean that it will be
tactical more than anything but this
this position they're all sorts of
dynamic threats that mvl needs to deal
with the B5 Pawn is under attack right
away as you mentioned Queen B6 might
walk into a pin and C takes D4 gives
white that C6 Square it's really vital
Black's best move would be B set B5 back
to B7 right let me push that pawn
backwards to cover some of my weeks
squares and that way my Pawn isn't
hanging on B5 and behind it on A6 so
actually it was a big commitment by
Maxime and now I think he might be
regretting a little bit as he drops down
to nearly two minutes B5 B7 would be a
game-winning move here it would
immediately equalize in fact we'd start
talking about a small Edge for black
finally a decision from the Frenchman as
he takes on D4 now Knight C6 here is a
distinct possibility is there an
exchange sack on C6 followed by D3 not
really White's defending that twice do
you think we're gonna see Knight C6 from
Magnus uh he's certainly going to think
about it and you see he's got his hand
on his head he's calculating because
Knight C6 Queen E8 that looks very
unappealing after Knight F3 takes D4 now
your knight C6 has another friend
protecting it the bishop on F5 is under
attack B5 and A6 behind it are
threatened so I believe that Knight to
six Rook takes c66 might kind of be
forced otherwise the position just feels
very unpleasant now you could actually
play Knight takes D4 immediately that is
an option and I know Magnus likes these
kinds of kg moves it's seems to blunder
at night but no white takes on F5 and
opens up the attack on blacks Knight
Magnus makes a third move as he takes on
D4 with the bishop so Robert he's trying
to keep the status quo and I think part
of the reason he's taken with the bishop
is to deprive the black queen of the B6
Square what do you make this I'm a
little bit skeptical to be honest great
move right there from Mexico Queen to D5
because that protects B5 it puts
pressure on B3 connects the Rooks on the
last rank there so everything kind of
working well for black and Rook takes C1
is a threat because B3 is loose and not
to mention after Rook takes C1 you also
put the next back on C the bishop 105
defense so Bishop F3 you're mentioning
Bishop E4 as a response even Rook takes
C1 with Queen takes B3 to follow white
has some things to figure out now so I
believe Bishop takes D4 was an
inaccuracy that allows Maxine to have
the type of play he has been seeking I
think it's a major inaccuracy and I
think now Magnus down 30 seconds on the
clock needs to start thinking about
bailing this game out he just completely
overlooked the move Queen to D5 and be
on very sharp to start off the game and
let's see if Magnus just decides to bail
out or is he going to keep pursuing
complications he trades once on B5 if
you want to draw here with white Robert
what do you think is the best way to
make it is it to take on C8 and just go
like 95 to D3 how exactly does white
stabilize this position it's a really
good question because the Knight on E5
is actually a bit loose once that Knight
hops out from F6 into E4 Bishop on G7
hits the Knight and the bishop behind it
so all of a sudden black is the one who
is unleashing the threats here and
Magnus he drops to a minute on the clock
Maxine with about a full minute lead and
the decisions are much more difficult
for Magnus all of a sudden that's the
difficulty of Chess one small inaccuracy
wasn't a blunder and now it's Maxine who
has the easier position to play it is
indeed and now his time Advantage has
ballooned to over a minute imagine what
a victory in game one of the black
pieces would do for his confidence
imagine what it would do for the Arc of
the match especially compared to how the
Fabby match started 30 seconds for
Magnus he finally makes a decision he
takes on cable he played Queen to A1 no
that drops B3 and as we predicted he
moves the Knight back to D3 but 94 even
here Robert needs to be seriously
considered because that Knight could hop
into C3 and wreak havoc on the
coordination of White's remaining minor
pieces yeah the dark scores are going to
be a problem for white so 94 looks like
an excellent first move I'm wondering
what Max team is thinking about what
alternatives there are you you know 94
just seems like the move I really am not
considering anything else
yeah but emotionally it's hard to part
ways with your grown-filled Bishop I
think any time you're giving away your
fianchetto Bishop that's a major
concession the thing is with only two
minor pieces left and only one pair of
Brooks you're not really worried about
King safety 94 is definitely the move
and if your Maxine keep your foot on the
gas pedal don't let Magnus get away with
this and I think he just did with the
slower move rook d8 and Knight F4 comes
with the tempo a shot against the queen
on D5 the B5 Pawn is still a little bit
loose the beat three punk you push the
B4 at sub moment well not after Queen D6
as you keep a queen A1 your idea now the
Knight Frozen in place you can play
Knight E8 that's an option but you're
retreating rather than going on the
offensive oh and Maxine trying to poke
and prod at magnus's King side he's
inviting the move F3 Magnus says hey you
want me to play F3 you got it and now
he's gonna move his Rook from F1 I think
into C1 or maybe D1 and suddenly White's
pieces are looking quite nice again they
are in fact uh this bishop on C6 staring
biting on granite as you'd like to say
the pawn in F3 is blunting its four
course no E5 breaks finally the bishop
is traded but now it looks like we've
liquidated into a pretty solid position
but there's nobody better on the planet
and winning positions just like this
than Magnus Carlson just Buckle in and
watch Magnus down to 18 seconds this is
what might give mvl the resources he
needs to draw it should be a draw but
how many of these end games has Magnus
won just in the SCC alone not even
talking about throughout the course of
his chess career I think he wants to
play E4 Robert to further restrict
Black's minor pieces and of course if we
compare the B5 Pawn is far more
accessible of a weakness than the B3
pawn and eventually Magnus could try to
attack it with his Bishop knock the
bishop off of the diagonal but mvl says
no I'm staying on E8 this is much worse
for black I don't care about the evil
bar the king is sprinting to D4 maybe
it's a C5 and what is black doing
playing on the king side but here comes
the white kickoff oh G3 take off air
Magnus and he restricts the night mbl's
gonna play F6 I think you know he goes
outside desperately desperately trying
to manufacture counter play but what is
accountable F4 you can just play G4 kick
the Knight right back G5 no this is
winning oh my God H3 it's over how did
he do that again and Bishop takes B5
Robert the worst thing is that's gonna
it's gonna force a bishop trade and
knights are the worst piece at stopping
passers King C6 1-0 also night and games
are most similar to King and Pawn in
game so white is just simply up a pawn
no counter play whatsoever the Knight on
E5 protecting everything now goes back
to D3 so you push B4 and B5 and the
black king if it tries to stop the beat
Pawn the white king goes over the king
side not to mention that Knight E4 is an
Unstoppable threat it's gonna pick up a
second pawn and then the third one is
going to fall and Magnus Carlson has
done it again in game one oh my gosh
here we go with this again he is
incredible just when it seemed like
Maxime had no problems with the queen D5
Maxine plays that sloppy move Rook to d8
he didn't jump forward he instead played
a bit passively and that's when Magnus
pounces he's a one-nothing lead but look
at Magnus by the way with the black
pieces playing this Modern Line this
kind of rat variation he's not striking
in the center with his Pawns it said
he's staring at the center with his
bishop and maybe with his other Bishop
theme carrying the B7 he'll do it with
both and Magnus is enjoying himself in
the early going of this match he's
taking mvl out of his comfort zone and
he's saying I don't care about I don't
want to Berlin I don't want to
sebastianakov I don't want a theoretical
dispute I want fresh interesting
positions and I want to be able to play
for a win with both colors but Robert
you took the words right out of my mouth
from a computer perspective mvl's
mistake came later than Rook d8 it was
still a drop but from a human
perspective Rook d8 was definitely the
culprit had he played 94 it was
basically a two result game a shocking
moment honestly in the early going and
these are the mistakes that you simply
cannot make against the world champion
if you expect to give him a run for his
money yeah Magnus is like kind of the
evil force in a paranormal movie they
sense fear they smell it they sniff it
out and then they capitalize and punish
you for it so Magnus he wins game one
but here in game two he's playing some
kind of cagey chess he has control of
the G4 Square his Knight or Bishop can
go there but look at White's play all
four minor pieces in a row Connect Four
you win not in chess unfortunately and
this Center is strong D4 and E4 so what
is Black's plan here down here what do
you see Magnus going forward with first
of all I happen to be terrible at
Connect Four so if you actually want to
beat me in a game I'm telling you right
now that's the one you should choose
what is Black's plan well black splan is
still apply pressure on White Center and
there we have Knight B8 to C6 a very
typical move and you might say why is
Magnus walking into D5 well think about
D5 from a positional perspective you're
opening up the bishop and you're
yielding black a very nice stronghold on
E5 and later on if we bring up an
analysis board here if white just
nonchalantly plays D5 after something
like Knight E5 you can see the Evolve
are dipping what can often happen Robert
is a move like C7 C6 chipping away at
White Center and once the queen comes
out to B6 it combines with the bishop
and the pressure on White's Queen side
can become very serious very quickly so
mvl avoids this with a 10 foot pole and
if we go back to the live board he has
decided on Knight C3 to E2 I think he's
going to follow up with C3 to cement his
center with his pawns oh that was a very
instructive line it shows the power of
the Phoenix Bishop which often happens
in a sicilian dragon or even in a
grundfeld so uh Knight C3 to E2
something that Wesley did very well
against Maxime retreating moves and
Magnus he says I'm not retreating I'm
hopping forward left and right Knights
on B4 and G4 you don't see this every
day and if Knight takes D5 back well
you're Knight is centralized but how
stable is it you will play C6 as you're
indicating but it's just a weird
position right what is black really
aiming for
yeah I really don't oh I mean C7 C5
would be the pawn break you really want
to achieve but it's hard to do it as
long as the Knight remains on D5 Magnus
playing it more modestly you know what
the structure reminds me of is is almost
like a scandi or an alkyne once Magnus
played D5 the pawn structure changed
completely and there's no doubt in my
mind that white is better objective
better control of the center Etc yeah
you're gonna love this reference I was
saying this reminded me of a Sunday
tibiakov game like I'm looking at this
and I'm just like exactly you know the
legendary Dutch Grand Master formerly
over 2700 uh this looks like the type
game he would have from the black pieces
but look at Magnus he goes A5 he's
slowly pushing his pawns forward but he
wants to kick the bishop off the
diagonal but Maxim does it himself he
blocks that Bishop's path by playing C4
kicking the knight from D5 but I don't
know something about this feels way too
loose for white the D4 opponent in
particular
yeah I made an analogy a couple of
commentaries ago positions like these
resemble driving a bus I have no idea
how to drive a bus but it's hard to
maneuver this around tight Corners black
is a pretty compact position and the
good thing about not having any Pawns in
the center is that you're not
responsible for them white is
responsible for a lot of things in this
position let alone a big decision that
is now looming where is White going to
Castle both sides have major drawbacks
if you go Queen side you're walking into
some sort of a4a3 shenanigans if you go
kingside well you have a Pawn on H4
Robert and we know that that creates
serious long-term weaknesses I think
white is still better objectively but I
agree that the position is perhaps
harder to handle from a practical
standpoint yeah just because the D4
pawns sticks out like a sore thumb right
black at some point like E7 E6 which
keeps all of the pawns strong I like to
say this pawns are only a strong Pawn
chains I should say as their base Pawn
the D4 Pawn doesn't even have a pawn
attached to it the Knight on an F3 is
stable that's the good news but look at
this Knight H7 step one if we can
continue putting pressure on the D4
squared that'd be nice and Bishop E3
maybe not so appealing because the
Knight on G4 can capture it I see the
eval bar saying white is doing well I
think you can play in the center with
your Rooks and keep everything steady
and Bishop F4 saying Bishop takes D4
please capture that Rook D1 is my
response great move by mvl because this
also prevents the pawn break e75 and in
the event of Bishop takes D4 Rook D1
doesn't actually win the bishop
technically did a C5 but I don't I'm not
even in the mood to discuss that line
there's no way back this bishop takes D4
here in that position of course white
has Knight C3 to B5 recapturing the
bishop with interest yeah this position
looks very nice for maxim I like that
well first of all he's eating again so
you know he's in good spirits but I also
like the fact that he's reacting
objectively he's not scared of Magnus he
never has been he beat Magnus in this
format and he's just saying let me make
standard principled moves and what does
Magnus have to show for the pawn A5 oh
I thought you were the prophet you said
he wasn't gonna do that
well I think it's a bad I think it's a
bad move oh
H4 is loose and something is he is he
sacking his work but how does this work
what if white plays Knight takes E5 here
maybe bishop what exactly yeah he is
sacking his Queen yeah 95-95 and after
Bishop E5 Bishop takes he's giving up
his Queen and he's saying that in return
he will get active Rooks and the type of
position Robert I almost called you
Magnus which uh frequently results in a
fortress I I know because the knight
from H7 can return to G4 and create
long-term problems on White's first
strike I still can't believe he's done
this can we just Shadow the feature chat
the username kiblitzers that is awesome
that person doesn't have a diamond
membership can I give that to them I
know it's not really my choice but
somebody give that person a diamond
membership for that username if they
don't already have one but either way it
is going to be a queen sacrifice at this
point I believe Queen takes H4 is a
blunder F3 back always look for
retreating moves that would be a fork so
Bishop takes E5 Rook d8 rook d8 and the
good news or Magnus is that there aren't
too many Targets in his position the
queen is better than the rook and the
bishop but as you're highlighting that
Knight will get back into the game the
F2 Pawn will be a Target that's not a
dark Square it's a bishop that can land
on D4 and there are two open files there
are two Rooks
there are indeed two Rooks and white has
only one Rook an mvl attacking perhaps
the only Target in Black's position that
tender B7 pawn and I think he's going to
contribute to that by playing Knight E4
in response to Rook D7 try to get the
Knight around to C5 the issue as you
were pointing out earlier is that you're
weakening the second Rank and before you
know it black and infiltrate D2 and play
Bishop D4 flash just got more pieces
than white and that could cost white in
the long run let's see how Magnus
handles this position he had a similar
type of game against Fabiano caruana
where Fabi was winning at several points
and Magnus ended up turning it around
down a queen and winning it in the style
that he beat nepo in I think it was game
six right of the world championship yep
is also up nearly a minute on the clock
something that should not be uh
forgotten about is the clock plays a
factor here and Maxima has been very
good on the clock he lost game one I
know that was not an ideal ending but he
has been steady at Knight F6 look at
Magnus let's just trade Knights if you
take I take back H4 is loose I'll go
Rook F to d8 afterwards and you can go
from an A5 Pawn but that distracts
White's forces from some of the critical
squares if white does in fact go for the
queen side maybe Magnus will go for the
king side Sriracha mvl says no I don't
want the trade I don't want to play
without risk I want to win this game 94
to C5 inviting Rook D2 but I think he's
got Queen E3 in response forking the
rook and Bishop that was great tactical
awareness for Maxime and he forces
magnus's Rook to stay on the seventh
rank but still Robert you can't take on
B7 on account of Rook B8 how is Maxine
gonna turn up the pressure dial in this
position because you know Max is about
to go Knight G4 Knight G4 looks very
promising he goes Rook to EA oh watch
every background checkpoint by the way
that's why he goes G3 but the problem
with playing G3 is now you're not going
to be able to play F3 to kick the Knight
out so you've committed your Pawn
structure in the dark squares F3 would
be way too weakening that Knight would
go H6 to F5 and start attacking those
dark squares so I think while the eval
Bar says Maxime is favored I'm not so
sure in a Blitz game but that's why I
like Max seems clock management he is
ahead on time he can figure out these
complications with that lead I don't
know though I don't see a way for him to
improve on the queen side and Magnus now
has all sorts of shenanigans on the
other side of the board I'm even
thinking about sacrifices with Rook you
one to follow and this is all going to
come true if White's Rook departs the
first rank so MBL is kind of Frozen here
he has so many squares and so many
tactics to keep track of and as we're
talking Robert he's already dropped to
50 seconds on the clock if this gets
down to a Time scramble I think black
actually holds all of the cards here if
the bishop gets to the A7 G1 diagonal it
might be over so Bishop B8 foreign
and rookie 2 all at once you're
unleashing the power of those pieces
you've made this comment it may have
seen like a very obvious one black has
more pieces you have a rook and a bishop
for a queen even number of Pawns a rook
and Bishop can team up on a square a
Queen by itself tonight that seems the
mistake is Rook B8 just the response
rugby eight what does that means but
takes in Bishop D4 creates made threats
against White's King I think Magnus
might go for that alternatively is there
Bishop takes G3 maybe I like Rook B8 I
mean I understand Rook dhek is happening
but with the time trouble ensuing
magazine of 12 seconds he plays it back
to 14 and now we're gonna see a swap
Bishop D4 F2 is fun oh Bishop takes F2
is a dagger followed by rookie one
Magnus infiltrates with his pieces Rook
G1 is a huge right three he had rookie
three as well oh he did and queen B8
check there would have been forced he
plays it anyway okay the good news is
that Queen protects the G3 Square that's
huge maybe I'll just munching on the
Pawns of these three pawns up on the
queen side oh gosh and where's that King
going Bishop A7 check a huge threat oh
my gosh it is a huge thread King H3 gets
checkmated Bishop A7 anyway rookie yeah
it is a draw King F3 and King G2 back
rookie three rookie two don't go crazy
if you're Maxim take the draw and same
goes for Magnus what a game I love you
giving the Searching for Bobby Fischer
advice take the draw Maxine does just
that unlike in the Hollywood film and we
see a the lead remain one point from
Magnus Carlsen but Maxine Buster legrof
showing he is not going down without a
fight and he just gave Magnus all he
could handle in that game that was just
a high level game of chess it was an
interesting opening it was a cagey
middle game you could argue that MBL had
the advantage throughout the game but
that decision to sacrifice the queen
that's what makes the world champion
special just the understanding that he
would have enough activity with his
pieces
it's among the hardest decisions you can
make in chess when to sack the queen for
a rook and a peace robber because often
that just loses the game on the spot
great stuff from both players to score
is one and a half in magnus's favor yeah
we like to call that a great great
practical decision by Magnus to give up
the queen and for Maxime well I like
that he's going back to his opening from
game one the opening was not the problem
that's not the reason he lost sometimes
you have a result impact your psychology
no the opening was fine but look at
Magnus he's just playing this comedy H3
keeping the tension last time we saw D
takes C4 happen and Magnus took with the
Knight that's not gonna happen in this
game because you don't have C5 as a
follow-up you've already committed your
a pawn so one thing that black will try
is A5 to A4 at the right moment trying
to develop The Rook on a starting square
but there's just something about Black's
minor pieces here that are reminiscent
of I don't know middle schoolers at a
dance there's just a kind of an inherent
awkwardness that Bishop on F5 doesn't
have a way back the bishop on G7 is
biting on granite white has slightly
better control of the center so MBL has
deviated from game one in that he's
played C7 C6 rather than his approach in
that game which was to actually take on
C4 it's a slop setup it's a very solid
setup but do you kind of see what I'm
saying Robert it's just a little bit
harder to handle Black's pieces here
maybe Knight F6 to E4 is what the doctor
ordered and you called it A4 well one
thing I'm worried about for black is
this bishop 105. you highlighted this in
the previous game G4 is even an idea for
white because where's the bishop going
it goes to E6 or to E4 the Knight and F3
hops to G5 and is going to take that
Bishop off the board so maybe first you
have to deal with some of the things
happening on the queen side here A4 to
A3 is possible a takes B could be a bit
annoying uh so even B takes A4 I know
often we don't like to take that pawn
doubling our own because ba for Queen A5
looks like the response is to gain that
pawn back but the B7 Pawn of the Target
and very importantly the bishop on F5
it's not stable G2 to G4 looks like a
viable option I'll show this on the
analysis board it's uh a great Point
Beats takes A4 always has to be
considered then you have to start
calculating Queen A5 the good thing for
black is that if white blindly goes oh
that's a free porn no it's not Rook fb8
Queen C7 and at the very least you can
take B2 Robert apparently did white have
something in this position Queen B3
Oh
What A Move what a find
and if you take it the Rook on A8 is
pinned you're a beast so you have to go
with the other Rook you have to play
Queen B7 Rook Aba
wow that is actually a sick line I'm
glad we're able to show that I don't
think that uh there's gonna be this
variation but that is some cool stuff
showing that usually you go have to be
to trap the queen oh here The Rook on
eight being loose allowed white to sack
the queen and with great effects so what
a line oh my God Queen B3 and the queen
extricates itself from danger okay back
we go to the live board that was fun but
he's not playing B takes A4 and as we're
talking Magnus is thinking he's taking
the longest think of the match thus far
as he drops now to 245 on his clock and
B4 is his decision
yeah I think that I don't hate it even
though the evil bar is saying that was
wrong because now this Pawn A3 it's a
long-term weakness you've gained some
space but if pieces get traded off the
board the A3 positive Target as you're
highlighting that Knight can just hop
right around into White's position that
is the downside of allowing the pawn to
go all the way up there yeah that pawn
is an anchor point you could actually
get your knight conceivably to the B2
square and maybe even around to D3 so
black has positioned his Pawns in kind
of a weird looking way where there they
are weaknesses right they need to be
defended carefully but they can also
serve as anchor points for outposts for
Black's night let's see which side of
these pawns prevails by the way C5 looks
impossible because both B4 and D4 cover
the square but because there's a pin on
the diagonal black could consider the
move C6 to C5 chiseling at White Center
now Magna is the big decision here his
Knight and F3 is under attack does he
want to go forward Knight to E5 I don't
like the look of that because after the
swap on E5 of knights the queen goes to
C7 and E5 is immediately threatened so I
think the Knight has to retreat
somewhere the question is where
he Retreats it to D2 you now have to
reckon with the idea of G4 knocking the
bishop away from its defensive E4
although in in some of these positions
we we see black sacrificing upon like
that in order to induce a weakening of
White's King side I think Magnus has the
slightly more comfortable game and MBL
definitely the one who's got to make a
couple really committal decisions in the
next few moves Robert
yeah not easy G4 a big threat as you're
saying sometimes you allow that to
happen and you just do the one look
Knight of six defending the pawn G4 fell
but G5 wins the E4 Pawn but it gives up
H3 and you do not want to see that
happen so I think that white should play
the simple chess Rook to B1 Rook to B3
and maybe Quincy won at some point I I
know I'm just focusing on that A3 pod
because I said it could be a weakness
but how are you gonna keep it defended
hey as Abraham Lincoln said a pawn is
upon as a pawn you couldn't get that
Rook around he gets his Queen to B3
which serves two purposes first of all
Knight D2 to B1 is a distinct
possibility once you win this Pawn the
floodgates kind of open on the queen
side the second idea of course is to
keep pushing on the queen side with B4
B5 and maybe even carve out the B4
Square for the bishop so you can combine
these two ideas and you're essentially
asking black what what are you gonna do
to me on the king side is MBL gonna go
like H5 Queen D7 King's Indian attack
style well I don't think that's
effective either white can also always
drop a bishop back to F1 Robert to
prevent any shenanigans on H3 well he's
not H5 what if he had started with Queen
D7 because Bishop takes H3 felt like a
threat even if it didn't lead to
Checkmate so in this order you're 100
correct on it Queen D7 can always be met
a queen C8 interesting move I think he
wanted to say out of the Brook's path
but Bishop F1 looks very pleasant for
white G5 G4 it just feels a little bit
slow for black but at the same time it's
Blitz chess and Magnus Carlsen down just
to a minute and 28 seconds and he says
I'm not afraid if Bishop takes H3 come
at me because the bishop on E2 in the
resulting position is going to guard
this very important G4 Square moreover
even if black does play Knight G4 it
won't carry a threat because the Knight
on F1 is the real hero of the king side
E5 by Magnus start your engines on the
queen side and mvl's got to make some
decisions here and he's got to make them
quickly C5 is his response taken in
Bishop D4 or Bishop Bishop exactly nice
movement he wants the C5 Pawn back and
he's getting it and the A3 Pawn is
better protected because the dark Square
Bishop's off the board but what about a
move I was thinking maybe C6 and B6 but
you're probably gonna end up losing that
pawn oh B6 threatens C5 and you can't
take because of the fork on C5
that was intuition by Magnuson he played
C6 and now he's thinking I think he
thought C6 is the best move let's play
it because you've secured yourself a
pass Pawn if that pawn were back on B7
your quote unquote passed Pawn on the C
file is stuck in place now even after a
swap on B5 the C4 Pawn takes back you
have a clear pass Pawn so great decision
by Magnus even if he did have a
follow-up ready but what is that thought
Rook C1 that is a good strong stable
move and Donya white is essentially up a
pawn because black has these double e
pawns whereas white has a passer on the
queen side
he might be up upon virtually but he's
down two minutes on the clock let's see
how Magnus handles I would say for the
first time in three matches a situation
where he's got 20 seconds to his
opponents two and a half minutes MBL
he's playing quickly and I love the way
he's managing his time early in the
match but can he actually cash that in
C5 I think Magazine with C5 here because
that forces CB and then Bishop takes B5
back and White's pieces are getting
active and your spring for your past
Pawn the move is not liked by the
computer but the Knight is starting to
sink its teeth into that D3 square
there's also
the old idea of Quincy and Bishop takes
H3 which is much stronger now with the
Knight being able to access F3 eight
seconds as Magnus blitzes out Rook D4
well Bishop takes H3 is so tempting here
oh magazine refrains C5 is protected for
now but C8 C8
how do you defend it oh my goodness this
this might be getting out of control for
Magnus Maxim totally turned this game
around what play by him
and just take it with your queen
or do you go
Knight takes C6 Knight C6 looks flimsy
another great move take C1 he's winning
oh he's completely winning
and he's losing on time he's losing on
the board I think Knight C6 was a fork
oh my gosh the creature E7 Falls loose
no this is over no rookie one pinning
the Knight Magnus pinned Seven Ways to
Sunday here he can't even move no he
cannot and uh will remain where else
because they won he might go repeat two
at night D3 and just go for the F2 Pawn
no no but give me a downside to Rook A1
he goes for uh I don't like that at all
you don't want to give Magnus a second
chance the guy can pull anything out of
a hat and if Knight D3 Bishop C4 Knight
62 Rook A2 forces the Rooks off I know
black is up two pawns but with double
pawns that might give Magnus chances he
goes Rook A7 he's going for the attack
listen MBL is playing with some serious
fire now his material advantage has been
reduced Rook B2 was Unthinkable rookie
one was resign time and all of a sudden
it's a game again he should still make
it down to three seconds he wants Rook a
two perhaps he has in his back pocket if
he wants to trade Rooks he goes Rook A5
with the page
three and E4 was the thread he's gonna
lose
oh my gosh game
Maxim vashir lagrove Strikes Back in
game three it is an even match once more
and done it in their previous matchup in
2020 Max actually won the first two
games and Maxine still won the match so
in early deficit does not phase Maxim
vashir lagrav he has proven that before
and maybe he'll prove it again
and if you're a maxim you basically from
a psychological standpoint want to
convince Magnus that this isn't just
gonna be a repeat of the Fabby match
right you want Magnus to start thinking
hey I'm actually in worse form today
this is actually going to be a much
closer match that's what I mentioned in
the pre-show you want to get under the
world champion skin there's no better
way to do that than to get off to a
start to the kind of start that he has
indeed gotten off to and Magnus
continuing to play ambitiously in the
opening kind of a martial Gambit and
let's see what he makes of this let's
see how that world championship match
preparation pays off what's going on
Rook takes D5 you're walking into a pin
but
oh my god oh I remember this there's
some e-file problem right so if we bring
up an analysis board this is super
instructive looks like Rick D5 yields
two pieces for what could possibly be
the idea but look at the e-file right
there's a weakness on E1 which black can
test with Queen E7 you have to drop your
queen back to D1 and I'm pretty sure
black just goes like Rook fe8 or rook
aea and you have no good way to defend
E1 you have to bring your king up and
now the queen dips into H4 what
attacking H2 that was not a very good
whoop I apologize and after age three
whoop queen H Queen F4 infiltrating now
H2 G3 Queen E4 infiltrating H1 and black
is now completely winning look at that
line as you would say by hooker by crook
that Queen is getting in there's nothing
you can do and well that would be a
massive problem look at this yeah as
you're finishing this line off winning
material back and the king is weak and
White's Queen said hasn't developed so
look at this bishop D6 played by Magnus
Carlson and Maxine is thinking there's
also Bishop takes D5 we only talked
about Rook takes D5 there he plays it
and now I think black has to play C6 yep
he does that very quickly and if Bishop
takes C6 you swap Bishops and then take
this Rook on E5 that's the important
point a move ago if you took on D5 The
Rook was simply captured back and
White's had material so you're trying to
force this bishop onto another Square so
The Rook 85 does remain loose when all
is said and done what do you make of
that line is that a possibility for
right to sack The Exchange and then play
D4 on the end or does White's lack of
development preclude that possibility I
guess it does maybe it was worth
considering MBL just says hey I'm up a
pawn
there's a bishop pair white is
underdeveloped over there on the queen
side but I like this position from a
practical perspective for white like you
just develop your pieces how is black
going to prove that he has sufficient
compensation for that pawn
and there's a ticking clock here
literally and figuratively if you let
white play Knight F1 and Bishop F4 if
you disappear the dark squid Bishops uh
Robert then Magnus is going to be worse
positionally as well as being down upon
he's got to make something happen on the
queen side and that's precisely what
he's trying to do with A5 and you put
that politely he wouldn't be worse he'd
be lost Darkstar Bishops are off the
board just pluck him off Knight B3 to C5
really anything because white is up a
pawn and controls the squares you could
give one of your pawns back and still be
positionally winning so Knight goes to
F1 if Queen E1 you stop white from
developing because the bishop can't move
the Rook on A1 is loose maybe Queen E3
you mentioned Queen g430 Bishop H6
that's pretty clever as well yeah I was
thinking Queen G4 because Queen D7 is
also a threat in that position Magnus
definitely enticed by Queen E1 he's
thinking about it now the typical way of
getting the queen out is to play B3 and
Bishop B2 but that looks really really
awkward even if you do that the queen
drops back and that Bishop on B2 has
reached basically a dead end so let's
see if Magnus takes up the gauntlet here
with Queen E1 actually threatens Bishop
takes H2 check now Bishop H2 does not
work right now your queen gets trapped
so it looks like you win a pawn and you
even things up with obstacle Bishops but
after Bishop takes H2 and we can just
try to show that quickly on analysis
board sure he's doing exactly what you
said uh bringing the queen up right back
to you too the queen gets trapped
funnily enough on the F1 Square super
instructive all Retreat squares are
protected and the B5 Pawn uh precludes
the queen from evacuating to B5 or A6
instructive indeed back we go to the
live board because the Queens have been
traded he's played Bishop B2 and rather
than bringing his Queen all the way back
Magnus trade Queens a lot of players
Robert wouldn't do this because they're
down upon but Magnus believes that the
activity of his rook and the pressure
exerted by the queen side pawns fully
compensates for them upon and moreover I
think black is just better here I think
MBL has misplayed this bishop A6 to D3 a
huge threat right now and something that
super Grand Masters do is they'd rather
be down upon with activity than equal
material and passive so right now Max is
showcasing why that is the bishop is
going to slide to a new diagonal into
the white position the A2 Pawn is always
loose the bishop B2
it's really a Pawn on B2 it's not really
doing much of anything and then black
has no problems whatsoever across the
board so Knight G3 is possible but the
Rook can just slide over he takes first
on B4 at least he gets an open file
maybe something he can use as the game
continues yeah tactically he will try to
get his Rook to C1 if the bishop leaves
uh B7 the issue is that even if it does
you always have Bishop D6 to f8 covering
a back rank check so magnus's next move
is very obvious you called it Bishop A6
maybe bishop C8 to F5 is an alternative
maneuver mvl has to try to get this
Knight out but at some point he's gonna
have to smoke the stroke you can't
survive for very long with a rook just
sitting there on E2 this is a very
specific variation that you know might
be relevant is that if Bishop A6 perhaps
The Rook can slide to C1 because there's
Rook C6 hitting both Bishops at once and
the back rank problems may keep uh White
in the game now that's easier said than
done it's a bit of a complicated line
but I'm just noting that those Bishops
would be on the same rank so perhaps The
Rook can cause the bishop some trouble
and perhaps given time black should just
make some Luft either H6 or King f8 not
because of the threat of a back rank
mate but precisely because of the line
uh that you indicated once the dark
squared Bishop is eliminated the the
mate conversation is reopened Knight G3
by Maxim and now imagine this has to
decide whoa I was not expecting that
were you I think he's saying let's just
make a draw you know I'm fine maybe he
didn't really believe in his well he's
walking into trouble
but then I guess you go back to G1 so
you don't lose your Bishop but he missed
it but Bishop D3 Rook C1 that's what I
was saying earlier the back rank
Checkmate saves white from losing a
piece but what if you just make a pawn
move like H5 or something H5
H5 G6 and I think that's what Magnus is
deciding how do I want to make Luft H5
is good because it also restricts
White's King side crippled kingside Pawn
structure wow Bishop D3 is a threat so
the bishop will have to move from B2 and
then you lose A2 and black is better
Magus is not making a draw here uh maybe
he thought that white was frozen no
matter what he plays this H5 move and
Bishop C1 Rook takes A2 this is not very
pleasant unless white can attack the
pawn and B4 that's the ultimate goal is
trading off B3 which is on the light
Square for that B4 Pawn on a dark square
and if you try to close the mouse strap
after Rook takes a two with Bishop B2
again there's Bishop D3 it just shows
how how much of a liability The Rook is
when it's this passive it's eminently
attackable when it's on a light square
and I think mvl is just gonna have to
desperately get that Bishop around as
you said 2d6 once you eliminate this
Bonnet to drop is there rookie one check
forcing King H2 and they're playing Rook
D1 can you go for the D4 Pawn to get a
passer oh and the bishop can't move I'm
gonna have to go Rook A1 I'm gonna have
to spend a Tempo preparing Bishop B2 and
Robert even if Bishop B2 is played there
there's Rook to D2 so I think that's a
great idea let's show this on the email
Jack King H2 here let's say I play Rook
A1 now do you take this Pawn or do you
find an improving move maybe King H7
just to show the point you were making
before Bishop B2 Rook D2 is a problem
because you win F2 and then these other
two pawns are going to be major weakness
okay we're having something very similar
back we go to the live board Magnus
throw in the move Bishop D3 and then he
went rookie one check and G5 keeping the
tension and expanding on the king side
wow he's saying oh Bishop B2 I have
rookie two back the F2 Pawn still Falls
and the bishop is ready to slide into E4
this looks really tough for Mexico he's
also down on the clock Donya Magnus wins
these games in classical chess but in a
Blitz game a bullet scramble impending
feels not very pleasant yeah and he eats
these types of positions for breakfast
he won a game like this in the very
first game it was obviously a totally
different structure different pieces on
the board but similar nature of the
position he's slightly better he's got
some pressure and he always manages to
make something out of nothing what's he
thinking about is he thinking about
taking and going Bishop B1 that's gotta
be a draw though right yeah because the
bishop might wrap around pretty quickly
Bishop people immediately that's not a
good move because white could push A4
that would be hilarious though but I see
what you're saying swapping on A1 Bishop
B1 if the white Bishop doesn't get to
the B Pawn in time black simply gobbles
up A2 and B3 has a passer of his own and
you see the evaluation bar saying that
this is not winning for black from an
objective perspective Magnus Carlsen is
not winning this game but he's good at
posing problems but he has a problem
he's down to 30 seconds he's frittered
away his time advantage and now MPL is
the one 40 seconds up on the clock I
feel like rookie two is a risk-free move
worst comes to worse you can just repeat
with rookie one and here comes Magnus
Rook takes F2 followed I assume by
Bishop E4 you might throw an F6 I wonder
if that's what he was calculating but F6
will be done by King to G1 so he just
plays Bishop E4 right after the G2 Pawn
Rook G1 Rook Tuesday E7 that's huge but
then black should go through the D4 Pawn
what is critical to Black's winning
chances is creating a pass Pawn of your
own you know don't want symmetry you
don't want opposite colored Bishops just
shuffling you want to pass upon you can
push while you're hammering away the G2
pawn and that's the principle of two
weaknesses you're not going to win the
game just by putting pressure on the
spawn White's capable of Defending that
pawn in a watertight manner with Rook G1
what White's not capable of doing is
defending that pawn and restraining a
resurgent deep on at the same time mvl
sees that and he's trying to find an
alternative maybe the immediate Bishop
E7 should be considered but in that case
the king could actually get checkmated
pretty easily if it lands on H3 oh he's
going for it Rook G2 King h32
that was a mistake apparently
what if just Bishop takes before what's
his follow-up
I don't know
he goes to one first best move he
freezes the pawns so eight Pawn can't
push though dropping B3
check he's rookie so he wins A2 don't
miss Rook H1
uh-huh
okay King up it's time for the black
king to enter the party major practical
chances for black would you agree oh
absolutely King F5 King G4 already looks
scary and now king of five also throws
H4 and he misses yes he missed it it's
winning on the spot basic that is basic
Betty right there now H3 and the pawn is
Unstoppable yeah King H4 the pawn
remains defended don't go H2 because of
H.A check that's the one thing six Maybe
oh but Bishop six check oh it's a check
oh he goes King G4 now
Rook B2 he can just go out for the B
Pawn
and king oh he wants King F3 so he goes
Bishop F5 first really important move
tightening the screws Magnus is in no
hurry this Pawn is eternally defended By
the Light squared Bishop that is the bad
part of opposite colored Bishops you
can't attack weaknesses that are on the
collar of the opposing sides bishop and
he's also playing for mate he's gonna
deliver it that is a Magnus master class
that guy had what looked like nothing he
had a slightly you know more active
position he was down a pawn but he just
moves and he just pokes and prods in
ways that people cannot handle even the
best of the best like Maxine vashila
Grove and the thing to remember is that
Magnus does make mistakes right he gets
down to 30 seconds or whatever he does
make inaccuracies but even after he does
he takes his foot off the gas pedal for
one second he puts it right back on it
seemed like mvl was out of the woods
when he took that second Pawn on B4
Robert because it looked like that was
the only way black was gonna win and all
of a sudden Magnus switches gears at the
drop of a head he starts to play for
checkmate and he starts to play for a
king side attack just an Exquisite
display by the world champion and he is
back up by one
unbelievable technique I mean it's just
freakish the way he's able to beat
players in those positions we're back to
the opening we've seen in multiple games
and unfortunately for Maxime he hasn't
had time to look at this with an engine
to prepare it because he keeps going
back to it and we see the revenge is in
White's favor 0.7 but it's kind of an
nagging point seven we see the problems
in Black's position game after game the
C file the C6 square but he strikes with
B5 down here do you like that move well
he's setting up the pawn rhombus on the
queen side I think it's an interesting
approach because he's forcing Magnus to
make a decision to ride away now Magnus
can actually keep the tension by
bringing the bishop back that's kind of
a Magnus move if I've ever seen one just
go Bishop A1 keep your options as open
as possible if you take on B5 I don't
know how you're gonna follow that up
black seems to have all of the squares
all of the key squares on the C file
defended in particular the C5 square is
the one that you want to keep under lock
and key if you're Maxim and you
mentioned the C5 Square I was gonna say
if white plays C5 you close down the
queen side that's where activity has to
come from so a good decision to trade
and wow B for an unexpected move from my
point of view but the Knight can go B1
to C3 or B3 it's a c or A5 causing black
some problems but that B4 Pawn done if a
b a b and Rook A4 for example oh is that
B4 Pawn that long for the sport
I think that's a great point I also
think after a b a b two can play at that
game black can go 98 D6 to C4 and he
actually might be faster and I'm pretty
sure that Magnus might have only
considered the other Knight jumping into
C4 and he realizes that that's not
possible what about the F6 Knight hey I
want to join the party too 98 is a
brilliant rerouting move and I would
think that Wesley so would spot an
instant he did that really well in his
match against Maxine Buster legrov in
the quarterfinals but 98 it just feels
difficult because you want to make a
move like Rook A4 or Rook A2 or Knight
B6 but all those have drawbacks even if
you could play Rook A4 takes B4 in one
turn there's Bishop A3 to follow winning
and Maxim finds the move that you
pointed out Knight to E8 to D6 to C4 and
here we go the classic scenario both
nights reaching for the Outpost and
which Knight is going to be more
effective Knight C4 comes with Tempo and
now if you wanted to you could support
it with Knight D7 to B6 this position
gives me a headache too much happening I
know well it's too clogged up what do
you attack that's the big question the
reason why Maxim does not take on C5 is
well actually white contain with either
Pawn but B takes C5 gives white a
protected pass Pawn we talked about
Connect Four F2 to C5 that's an
impressive Pawn chain and now is your
highlight Knight to A4 is the threat the
B5 Pawn is protected Knight A4 if you
take on A4 B takes away oh gosh where's
that I think Magnus is the one who needs
an Excedrin because he is stumbling
around here back to B1 D1 he goes the
good news for white is to your point
there isn't all that much to attack on
the queen side so believe it or not
white is still pretty solid but he's
incredibly cramped and there's no
question that Maxime is firmly in the
driver's seat he's gonna double on the a
file you might play Knight B6 to A4 and
you got to be really careful there not
to get your queen trapped if you're
Carlson
the Magnus has almost no moves it feels
like right black is having all the fun
here he plays Knight T5 he's like let's
get some pieces off the board if you
take with your knight on E5 you win the
pawn on that square 95 D takes Bishop
takes we swap everything but the B5 Pawn
is loose so what Max is claiming is I
have less space my piece are restricted
let's get some trades going that way I
have more room to breathe and this is
the kind of nagging annoying move that
is a hundred times more annoying when
it's played by the world champion right
you start doubting yourself am I really
better or is my opponent getting a lot
of activity here a big decision to be
made for mvl what are the candidate
moves here I don't really like Knight
takes C5 unless he finds a convincing
follow-up I thought about an exchange
sack on C3 but that just doesn't look
very effective what else comes to mind
maybe a slow move like Rook to A2 just
try to intensify the pressure maybe even
F6 he does take on E5 but you were
correct again it was not the right
decision the liquidation helps magnus's
pieces breathe and now the queen goes
into the beach
or Bishop C6 and B5 that's even better
it looks like you attacked The Rook push
the pawn now you have an outside passer
but I love your move as well I think
Queen D4 equalizes comfortably
Bishop D3 a lot of puzzling decisions
here Robert in this middle game yeah so
he gets the trade and now we're gonna
trade Queens
well you can never say draw when Magnus
Carlsen is playing but this position
does look like we're gonna see Queen
before Knight takes D5 I think in that
position we could say draw although I
would still be quivering in my boots if
I was playing Magnus and black you could
have a rook and three against rook and
three and I would be nervous you could
have just King versus King and I'm still
shivering in my boots
but in all Sears this queen before
Knight takes D5 it's Mass liquidation it
means the game will Peter out into a
draw everything defended no weaknesses
um so Queen two Rooks and four pawns per
side so I think right now Maxime is
saying I feel like I should be better I
was better let me find something but
ultimately there's nothing it'll Peter
out into a draw it will pull out into a
draw
however you want to put it E5 by mvl I
think he's still playing ambitiously I
think he's saying hey I don't just want
to draw I want to equalize the match
before the halftime break and Magnus
can't just you know sloppily take on B3
because he's gonna be a pawn down in
that position and it's not going to be
easy to draw he has to move the Knight
but wait a second then black takes B4
well I guess what's underestimated the
chances here Rook C6
oh that's clever sorry to cut you off
Robert no no I was gonna say we
underestimate the chance here but even
that isn't so clear right e takes F4
Rook takes B6 we swap Queens E3 is loose
like that's something that you know
there's still some activity there for
black that white will have to handle
properly that said if Rook C6 is played
with all the pieces getting traded off
of course that gives Magnus great
chances to hold and I would argue that
if Rook C6 is in fact played and I think
it will be played we're likely to get a
Liquidation on the queen side and a a
three on two on the king side with which
given the pawn structure which is
totally fine should be pretty easily
holdable for Magnus I can guarantee you
he's calculating Rook C6 right now and
he's played it good stuff by the world
champion I think this is the way to hold
this position you sound like Charles
Barkley there I can't run to you and he
plays it Rook C6 hits the Knight on B6
and if you remove the guard to the D5
Pawn down it goes but what we were
talking about is if e takes F4 The Rook
takes that Knight on B6 the Queens get
traded E3 Pawn is captured why I start
seeing some chances for blacks if the
Brooks could get on the second rank
there then that white king feels like
cultural I don't think you're in time I
think that black uh doesn't get those
winning chances that you you would
desire so Rook C6 was an excellent
excellent choice it was and if you think
about it in the resulting end game white
could easily plop a rook on the second
rank when the time is right either
offering a rook trade uh if black beats
him to the punch or just guarding the
second rank from both of black Strokes
mvl looking for a way to muddy the
waters here but I think he's just got to
take the queen and no he doesn't he goes
Rook B8
oh wait okay whoa
there must have been a better move I
think he what Magnus is saying is that
he's got a lot of piece activity here
he's gonna go Knight C3
okay I buy the activity but I also love
an extra pawn and it's a healthy
opponent that
it is and MBO could support that extra
Pawn with Rook B8 to d8 he needs to
properly apportion the work for his
Rooks he goes Rook C4 yeah and if you
take D takes C4 goes Rook D6 now there's
no Knight C3
oh my goodness
and Knight D7 Rook takes B8 and Rook d8
oh my God boy you can't do that he
simply blundered a full night here and
then I can just move away from me too
Knight G3 and it's not totally over you
could make a couple more moves but
Magnus is not letting this one out of
the bag it's a full piece that is
shocking and the reason why is the king
is on f8 if the king were on G7 black
stays in this because now he's their
Knight D7 there's Knight C8 where you
lose the Rook on B8 but you take the
Rook on D6 but Knight C8 is meant by
Rook takes B8 with a pin over there oh
and that's such bad lie and this is the
ultimate bad luck Rook d8 check without
that move black would have been totally
fine and they'll still going to try
these positions are not the easiest to
win uh Robert and I've seen I've even
seen like Knight in three versus rook
and three get butchered but something
tells me Magnus is not not gonna let
this one slip maybe even F4 should be
considered here what you're trying to do
is carve out the D4 Square for your
knight he goes out H4 similar he wants
to reroute that Knight to the G5 Square
something like that eventually but
Knight F1 it's a slow process to play G3
King G2 the one thing you don't want for
white is to trade all of the Pawns
no he just he's done he's like I'm I'm
done with this he's done he gets a break
so luckily for him he can be done with
the game we see Magnus Carlson in his
room going away running off probably
just you know counting his lucky stars
that was huge that was huge and that is
the only blunder I mean you can't even
afford to make this blunder because at
the very least it would have been a one
point match ampl could have pressed that
end game for an eternity he was just up
a full Pawn instead he get gets that
game out of control he loses it and all
of a sudden he's down two points in the
match Robert these next two or three
games are going to be absolutely
critical on the break it comes at the
right time for the Frenchman he's got to
take a breath right now he certain does
he can snack up some food he can stretch
his legs get some air but he needs all
the help he can get after this start
down two games to Magnus Carlson but
while the players they go on break we're
gonna do the same but before we do we
want to remind you of the state of
chess.com coming your way Wednesday
December 21st live with Magnus Carlson
we are announcing some huge news for the
chess Community followed by Community Q
a with Danny wrench the guests include
the one and only Magnus Carlson who you
see in this match will be taking your
questions into chat you don't want to
miss the show December 21st at 10 A.M
Pacific Time right here on twitch.tv
chess we'll be right back for more from
the speeches Championship we'll see you
soon everybody
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess but with a duck quack quack
how to play duck chest the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck click on a
square to place the dog
oh he put the deck to prevent moves of
opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the pawns King to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemate but still wait there is
still meat but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the fast time winning
duck chest
oh no no no no no no slip no no no no no
no
ah duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
was that a persimmon that you just bit
into or is that a pepper I think that
might have been a persimmon well if it's
a pepper his plate needs to get spicy
and right now he is down by two but back
in 2020 when they faced off they squared
off in the semi-final the speed test
Champion Maxine Buster legrop he
actually won the five plus one time
segment he won the three plus one time
second by the an identical score four
and have three and a half and then tied
the one plus one four to four winning
13-11 some long games drawn out games
there not too many games overall the
match just 24 games total but he was the
winner against Magnus Carlson
it was the winner indeed it was a close
match all around an mvl early in this
match seemed to be repeating that
narrative after losing the first game he
equalizes the score I said that he's got
to keep it close in the five plus one
you can't let Magnus pull away because
Robert as the next game is about to get
underway one thing we take for granted
is that these top guys they defy human
nature human nature is to take your foot
off the gas pedal when you've got a big
lead Magnus and Hikaru they do the
opposite the bigger their lead the
better they start to play and that's
terrifying yeah you cannot get into a
deficit get into that hole because
Magnus Carlson will make you pay and we
are going to fix the match clock on
screen don't worry everybody uh there's
a little bit more time remaining than
you see there but either way we are off
we see that Maxime has Castle rookie one
we're getting standard Spanish fare
and another Marshall another Marshall we
saw a fascinating line by Magnus in
their fourth game and now he does
exactly the same thing have the players
look this up during the break see this
is what I'm always fascinated by and you
know the engines that they use they have
these super computers that are oh yeah
well really in-depth so even though it
says 0.4 right now perhaps magnus's team
looked at this another 15 moves saying
black is actually A-Okay but Bishop E3
uh that move closes down the file The
Rook is not on E2 this time the Knight
can slide behind the bishop to D2 and
then you reroute it to the king set or
to the B3 Square as you mentioned
earlier and nowadays we take engine
recommendations for granted but around
2004 2005 very often engines gave
incredibly misleading evaluations there
was a famous story during Vladimir cram
next world championship match against
petroleko and versago 2004. this was
actually in a marshall cram next team
plugged in a position and they let the
computer set for about a minute
famously lecco's team plugged in the
same position and let the computer sit
for about a minute and 10 seconds and it
turned out that in those additional 10
seconds the computer changed its
evaluation from winning for white to
winning for black and it was indeed
completely winning for black and Peter
like a won that game in one-sided
fashion nowadays even if you leave the
computer for three or four seconds it's
normally going to give you a pretty
accurate evaluation but that wasn't
always the case folks
it was not and right now Magnus he may
be down a pawn but he strikes with B4
he's saying Knight on B1 not going to D2
just yet the C3 Pawn will fall so if you
take on B4 then the bishop just takes
back and you similarly can't develop the
Knight so easily so Rook C1 black shows
the E file white controls the C file and
Daniel I mean it is an extra Pawn white
has a two on one advantage on the queen
side and the bishop on B7 would much
prefer to be on the F5 Square and
there's a high probability that this
position eventually transforms into an
opposite colored Bishop middle game or
end game as their previous game in this
line did we remind you that Magnus won
that game with an end game master class
as you called it for the time being
white is keeping his Knight alive now
where is this Knight going to go are we
going to chill on D2 if you're mvl or is
he going to try to go around to C5 who
benefits in the event of a bishop for
night trade I think that you would like
to get the Knight to C5 and what Magnus
would like to do is place the pawn I was
gonna say an A4 A5 before I could say it
but Knight B3 it could be a queen B5 as
well there's also uh the opportunity to
play A4 but as you're highlighting the
Knight does at long last get into the C5
square and does that provide real
winning chances that's the ultimate
question it's like those movie scenes
where the door is closing or the gate is
slowly closing and the good guys rushing
to get in before it does so the question
for why do you allow A4 maybe that's a
good thing for white man bianville says
hey that was misdirection the entire
time I don't think so I think he was
calculating Queen B5 and I think it's
likely that Magnus plays it
okay so Queen B5 Knight C5 uh the good
news for
for white is that even if you lose B2
you're just maintaining material
equality but I just feel like Maxime
hasn't found his footing in this opening
I mean Magnus look at him on camera
there he is chillaxed
oh totally chillaxed he's fine he's up
by two points he knows that he just won
an incredibly important game a gift by
MPL so this is what makes him so
terrifying a lot of players would be
nervous I gotta keep my lead Magnus just
becomes more and more relaxed
he does indeed and Rook takes the five
he took with the pawn and C5 there could
have been some D4 shots opening that
Bishop on the long diagonal so he takes
the Rook to keep the bishop closed down
white remains upon ahead the pawn on B2
is fixed uh Black's pieces are healthily
situated we might just see more and more
Trails healthily situated I'm gonna
steal that phrase
pretty healthily situated today how do
you feel
you know George Carlin would hate that
phrase he'd be like what are these
wording and excess terminology but right
now look at this move a near Miss hey
call It Here My Dear hit a near hit Rook
takes D5 is a huge blunder it looks like
a free Pawn but after Rook takes C1
there's let's show that check to follow
let's show that an instructive line and
you can take us through Robert rookie
one check that's just the start of
White's problems what now Bishop F1 and
after the King goes back not Bishop E2
Bishop E2 would have won the queen but
Bishop 18 is checkmated one this would
have won the game but Bishop H3 just
demonstrates The crucial importance of
weak squares in opposite colored Bishop
positions so white has to remain on top
here let's see how mvl tries to make the
most out of this extra Pawn I'm
skeptical I'm skeptical I feel like
Magnus he's got both of the queen side
pawns on light squares the bishop is
traveling to C4 I think he'll hold this
together yeah I do as well and one thing
that's very important especially in
blitzes is King safety Black's King is
tucked away at home no risk whatsoever
and now White's King has no risk because
the major pieces are coming off so this
looks like a queen trade bound to happen
and a draw would certainly be the case
if the Queens come off um you know Queen
B8 Queen B7 something like that as long
as Magnus doesn't drop a pawn
it's just an even position the funny
thing is you could probably even afford
to lose the D5 Pawn if the Queens are
traded there you put the bishop on D5
it's healthily situated on T5 and white
will not be able to make progress
Queen B7 I think MBL maybe wants queen
D6 so he still wants to orchestrate some
Shenanigans with his Queen but I think
you called it Robert you actually have
to be careful I know it sounds crazy but
if a bishop lands on H3 you could get
checkmated like within a millisecond
things could turn around and queen B1
back to E4 put on the yoyo string
already looks like a drawing mechanism
but perhaps Magnus wants to play King H7
and then get his Bishop out Queen in on
the light squares like it's that Queen
lands on F3 what already might be lost
oh absolutely Queen F3 and Bishop H3
that's the classic Lobster pincer
construction and B3 by MBL exploiting
the fact that Queen B1 check
relinquishes the contact with the bishop
so White's gonna have a pass Pawn here
and I think this is a good practical
chance for mvl how do you think Magnus
is going to respond King H7 Queen B1
Queen E4 I think is still a Perpetual
just wind up F3 there that's that's the
problem with this queen C2 check and
then actually white loses oh is that
worth showing yeah it's definitely worth
showing analysis board oh never mind
he's not just happened it might it might
just happen so we don't need to show F3
here would be a very bad move not
because a queen takes Bishop but because
Queen C2 check protects the bishop on C8
and attacks the B3 Pawn exactly very
good point Magnus is going to take a
little bit of time but we know what he's
going to do no reason to do anything
crazy for black here he's gonna keep his
two point lead in a solid draw with the
black pieces holding his own in the
opening is he the thing about playing
Queen C2 here no and then he takes a
king
he could try to play for a win it's not
out of the question nah but I think I
think he would do it if he wasn't up by
two in the match yeah there's no real uh
reason to do it it is still a two-point
lead four to two now and Magnus Carlson
as Magnus Carlson does he's looking
disinterested while playing Amazing
chess
completely disinterested he seems to be
shaking his head every time he wins a
game
I I feel like that's something great
sports players and athletes do I've seen
Steph Curry do this after he hits his
6-3 in a row because he's six of seven
and not seven of seven that's kind of
what Magnus is doing in the gukesh
interview I know he's never satisfied
unless he plays perfectly I'm also glad
we got our first unnecessary Steph Curry
reference of the day
no Jimmy Garoppolo this time because
Brock Purdy's leading those 49ers in the
playoffs so I got you covered I know
your Bay Area sports teams I got it for
you but right now you're gonna have to
fill me in because C5 striking in the
center the bishop on G7 pinning the pawn
on D4 because the bishop on B2 is loose
behind it I kind of like this setup for
Maxime I think this is a big improvement
over what we saw in the early set of
games it is and I think this is more in
the spirit of the grunfeld and the
grunfels your Pawn doesn't normally
appear on C6 you try to play C5 in one
Fell Swoop
um so so the knight's gonna come out to
C6 and before you know it there's going
to be major pressure on the D4 Pawn I
think this is the way to solve the
opening problems and I always love it
Robert when the players actually look at
openings during the break it shows you
how seriously they take the match and
it's just it just adds another element
to these already epic uh duels
that was the most impressive swoop I've
seen since Cheryl swoops so good job by
you there and right now I feel like
there is pressure mounting against White
Center and Magnus he's spending a lot of
time right most of these games it feels
like he's down like 30 seconds a minute
quite early I wonder how that's going to
be when we get to the shorter time
controls but we still have 27 minutes of
five plus one and he goes Knight to E5
and now Knight C6 is played there's a
lot of tension in the center between the
knights and you could play very
positionally you could trade both pairs
of knights and say that you've damaged
Flex structure
he takes on e4 first so let's see how he
follows up against Bishop takes E4 some
Thanksgiving MBL cold feet what is it
hmm does she think about d e
I guess he might be but what is the
problem with Bishop takes E4 that's the
question you ask and well he answers
there is none but he took a little bit
of time to figure it out
there is the movie I've seen that idea
before but blackened just respond with
G5 carving out an escape score for the
bishop
so my guess is Magnus is playing
conservatively with C3 or maybe even C4
so if there's a trade on D4 and white
gets to take back with a bishop I feel
like that could be very pleasant for him
so even a move like Rook C1 comes to
mind just offering some trades on the D4
Square you'll eventually play C4 and
take over the newly compromised dark
squares on the queen side that said I
really like your idea to play C3 because
you forced Black's hand and the same
holds true if C3 you take on D4 Magnus
plays your move fcd4 is he gonna play e
takes D4 and keep the C6 Pawn backwards
or is he take back with the c pawn and
claim that I have a healthy Center and a
rook come to C1
and if we can pull up an analysis board
I think he is gonna well I think he's
gonna play CD I'll show this quickly I
promise I'll be quick cdcd
C5 looks good for black but if you
actually follow the line through to its
conclusion what you notice is that white
gets this massive and not massive in
terms of numbers massive in terms of
importance the pawn majority on the
queen side it's very easy to convert
this into a pass pawn and black is in
big trouble in a position like this even
if it's quote unquote only 0.6 in any
case Maxine goes Queen A5 back to the
live board we go and Magnus responds by
dropping the pawn up to A4 interesting
choice by Carlson what do you make of
this he wants some Bishop A3 ideas so
The Rook now defends the A3 Square so in
the event of a capture on C5 you'd
Bishop A3 but now after CD4 if we get C
takes D4 and C5 the one bad news for
white is that the pawns on a form B3
they're harder to push so look at that
Intermezzo plays B4 if the queen goes to
B6 now if C takes D4 Queen takes B4
Bishop A3 looks like it may win a pawn
but E7 can be defended so he just keeps
pushing pawns Donya he's throwing them
all at the board and if you can't play
CD4 he does I guess what I can Bishop A3
Queen b77 and this is what Magnus does
Queen A4 for play yeah he's like have
your extra point good for you maybe
throw an A6 to freeze the pawn on A7
situate the bishop on C5 and these are
the decisions I've used this phrase a
lot thus far these are the decisions we
take for granted just a seamlessly
interwoven positional Pawn sack that
gives him really nice practical play but
this is where I think mbl's extra 90
seconds can really come in handy
and will Magnus push this Pawn to A6
cementing A7 in place what Maxine needs
to do is Swing his Rook away from f8 and
play E5 he wants to open up the position
and get his Bishop his dark Square
Bishop into play look at the queen side
white can put a bishop on C5 and the
bishop on E2 is already staring down to
the A6 Square the bishop on e4 and the
bishop G7 not helping out so white has
the advantage on the queen side despite
being down a pawn so if black can
neutralize that activity then the extra
Pawn will make his presence felt great
insight there and on the basis of that I
was going to say move the Rook away from
C8 prepare a quick E5 strike and if
you're Magnus Carlsen what's your
priority are you trying to prevent E5 if
so you consider a move like Queen C3 or
you say I don't care about E5 because E5
doesn't actually create any threats well
as you mentioned what it does is it
allows the dark squared Bishop to
re-enter society and for black to create
a Target on D4 A6 by Carlson and it
looks like he'll follow up with Bishop
C5 if I had to guess yeah and The Rook
on F1 can go over to C1 and you're just
saying your Pawn on C6 is a backwards
Pawn cannot move and goes Queen C7 yeah
I think it's clear E5 is on the docket
maybe white will play F4 at some point
so fireworks preventing E5 oh and he
couldn't play Bishop D7 because the E7
Pawn was hanging at least that was maybe
one of the thoughts I guess Bishop takes
G4 there could have been considered
maybe bishop D7 is what MBL should have
played because now without E5 Magnus
essentially has a free free hand on the
queen side but look at mvl where he's
not going gentle into that good night
take that pawn and maybe play effort
oh and suddenly Black's the one who's
suffering on the king side is what
you're saying yeah no this looks like
Magnus is playing first on the queen
side the A7
what
I'm shocked by this
yeah he's leaving himself with a
terrible Bishop that's the problem and
this is what Magnus Carlson is doing he
gives up material for peace activity you
can't necessarily quantify how valuable
the activity is but here we see the Evo
say plus two that's the move E5 no but
here you can just take and even go with
a simple move like Queen G2 E5 in and of
itself does not carry a threat I feel
like MBL has completely lost the threat
of the game here he has and you can even
take on G6 right to just hurt Black's
King side position uh you can take on
that five first as you're mentioning
there's also some Merit to move E3 to E4
in some positions so a lot going on here
but you need to be careful if you're
Magnus look at the clock you're down
into nearly 50 seconds Maxime is over
two and a half minutes so if a mistake
happens it's likely going to be due to
time trouble but I think you made a
fantastic prediction HD first to clear
as much space as possible on the king
side the game is far from over but the
long-term problem for mvl is this
dreadfully weak A7 Pawn that's straining
his resources so much the queen on F7 is
going to be so close to being
overextended and maybe Carlson will lift
his Queen to G4 and just keep tightening
the Noose on Black's position
because it threads rookie seven
does he want F4 F5 or something he can
go for that he does
Bishop back to G7 that stops the potency
of F5 because it's no longer a pin but
Queen G4 still looks very promising
because it threatens Rook B7 a huge
throw what a move and Rook takes B7 you
pick up the for the C Rook with check
and then the B7 okay he's got to move
the Rook away from CN and he does but
now F5 looks good oh it's very powerful
Brooke crashing smashing through on the
king side it's over Bishop D4 coming
Rook G5 coming he's collapsing on all
sides and queen e6o's Rook f8 check you
don't want to put the queen on the same
Diagon as the other so where does your
queen go over to C7 that's away from
your king and moves like Rook G5 Bishop
D4 Queen E6 check in the future it feels
like the black king does not have any
defense black just has a couple of spy
checks but they lead absolutely nowhere
white skin can hide away on H3 just a
tropical island it's got its pina colada
and blacks days are numbered yes because
Queen C7 is my Rook f8 check with a
Checkmate
Checkmate mate in how many moves you can
play Queen H5 and Rook F7 and win the
queen and Magnus is probably gonna do
that yeah I'm gonna be able to
resignation occurs and look at Magnus he
kind of like flips his hand like what's
going on here he never seems happy
because he's hungry Maxime is well
nourished she keeps eating food and
what's Max's nourishment is winning
chess games and he's now up five to two
over the reigning world Blitz champion
God does he have a chip on his shoulder
Robert or what
I don't even know because he just feels
Unstoppable he did lose a game in this
match he didn't do that in the entire
match against five in a carwana but he
seems like he is just wanting this
Championship I mean he didn't get it two
years ago because of his opponent right
now and Vengeance it's a strong
motivator
it absolutely is and we have a pretty
conventional Roy Lopez a very popular
system with A3 and then Knight C3
traditionally in the Spanish you put a
Pawn on C3 and prepare D4 but in recent
years we've seen with the Advent of
computers players handling Marie Lopez
in a million different ways that would
have been Unthinkable before but my
question to you Robert is what happens
after Bishop G4 threatening the prosaic
Knight D4
it's a great question I'm glad enough to
answer it because I'm not a renowned
theoretician by any stretch of the
imagination
I was promised one thing they baited
switched me
yeah I'm glad that the moves have
happened so we can just move on from
that question and so here A4 played by
Maxine Bishop G7 now black has the pair
of Bishops at some point King H7 Pawn to
F5 things of this nature come to mind
it's kind of like a king's Indian which
means I defer to you as you are a king's
Indian expert and I play these types of
positions with black as well and I
always feel like when the moment black
plays F5 things start unraveling for
white on the king side so the operative
question is can Maxime create counter
play down the a file and you might say
well yes he can he can take and play
Rook A7 and maybe he should do that he
plays Rook K7 straight away but the C7
Pawn is well defended you're not gonna
win the game just by pressuring that
pawn alone you see Magnus there playing
in very circumspect fashion with Rook B7
the vaccine he's trying to harass him
with Rook Aid let's see if he can make
something out of nothing on the queen
side and it's good for black to keep
pieces on the board one thing I was
going to mention is it's not all roses
if the light score bishops come off that
dark Square Bishop on G7 is is a
terrible piece and the Knight can
reroute itself and improve so that is
what white ideally wants but for now
with a bishop pair King H7 Pawn F5 some
expansion on the king side and well if
you ever take on F5 that Bishop on G7
gets more life not to mention that black
can play H5 and Bishop H6 to use a new
diagonal at some moment but I like the
arrows that you're drawing Rook A7 give
me that a file but not so fast if we
swap on A7 Queen to A1 who's really
getting control of the eighth and at
this point Magnus could consider uh
factoring in the score I think if the
score was even he would be playing King
H7 in a heartbeat right now he's
weighing the pros and cons King H7 F5
looks good maybe mvl will Counter-Strike
in the center with D4 but the Mover okay
seven looks like the kind of move you
would play if you want to play with an
abundance of caution after the trade in
Queen A1 Black can move the queen away
from the a file maybe park it on B6 and
there are no easy infiltration squares
down the a file I still think King H7 is
more magnet systolic he is not satisfied
with the three-point lead he wants to
bring this up to five uh at the
conclusion of the five plus one portion
especially because playing Bullet at
this high level is kind of like playing
roulette you never know what's gonna
happen and you better be in your best
behavior because otherwise disaster can
strike so right now H3 played Magnus not
moving just yet he's down a minute and
it feels like that's where he wants to
be like he is down a minute every game
in this long time Patrol against Maxime
and I like your move Rook A7 I like to
move King H7 I like pretty much any move
I mean Rook
because Bishop E6 I was just so many
options there
there are a lot of options he goes for
Mass exchanges
and perhaps well you can't take on E6
that's the problem you have to trade Rex
first and now go Queen A1 perhaps but
Magnus could try to rest control of the
a file with Queenie 60 D7 Rook A7 the
Queen the White Queen alone is not an
effective piece at picking off Black's
weaknesses
right and queen A1 is played Queen D7
you called it and I guess for white you
could play the move B4 and he plays d46
in the center but I actually was saying
bomb two and Rook A1 but the reason I
don't like this is now that Bishop on f8
actually has a future
yeah and it can it has a future on G7 it
can combine with C5 which he plays me to
kind of benoni style carving out the
long diagonal and I think we need to
reopen the conversation about an
advantage to Black here we do look
that's a two-on-one pawn majority for
black on the queen side you could drive
that pawn to C4 later put your Bishop on
G7 or bring it to C5 for an attack at
the F2 Pawn you want to Target certain
squares and pawns F2 looks like a juicy
Target right for that Bishop to attack
as is B2 and even in the event of a
queen trade black essentially keeps all
of his advantages one of the long-term
problems is that white has a knight and
as we've already discussed Knights are
just not good at stopping past pawns
because they're a short range piece and
they can't really multitask is Magnus
gonna strike with C4 or is he gonna take
a more cautious approach with something
like Rook B7 what comes to mind if
you're Magnus here Robert I think he's
calculating C4 Queen D5 offering a queen
trade hitting the B5 Pawn but I think
after Queen D5 5 you can even just push
your putt up to B4 oh B4 and yeah you
have the C4 Pawn as a passer so Queen E3
is Maxine's choices Rook dc7 great play
you called us by the way you said if
trades happen whether it be the queens
or the Rooks black still is a huge
Revenge the pawn on B2 that's a dark
square and black already has outside
pass Pawn that white has to handle
yeah the the persimmon that MBL was
biting into furiously at the start of
this game doesn't seem to be helping and
Maxim a good decision there he has to
keep pieces on the board try to get your
Rook to A8 try to whip up some counter
play but Robert I just feel like Magnus
has entered that monster mode right
where he's totally in control of the
game and no matter what you throw at him
he seems to have the answer at the ready
yeah I think many players they get
scared by a rook A8 Queen B8 and attack
against the black king mags is not the
type of player he is so objective I was
talking about this on the right over to
the studio here where I was saying that
one of the things that Magnus does
better than anybody is he remains
objective he wins down the stretch he
goes into an end game if that's the
right thing to do he doesn't take the
speculative risk that you see others
sometimes make so you're pointing out
the move King G7 to get off the back
rank I like the look of that and it also
protects the H6 Pawn so Bishop C5 not
really enticing with H6 being vulnerable
a great move by Magnus a typical Magnus
move taking the sting out of Rook A8 and
as you're saying in comes the bishop and
let's not forget about uh the idea that
everything started with B4 and C3 black
is just a couple of moves away from
promoting the pawn and there are just no
targets there are no footholds for the
Knight and unless MBL can harness his
lead on the clock which I don't see how
he does
I feel like Magnus might just be only a
couple of moves away from striking yet
again with a free move black might play
Queen F6 as well trading the Queens
leads to maybe just a winning end game
and it attacks the queen and the B2 Pawn
all at once so I feel like white has so
many things to deal with the one sort of
counter play you can get is if you get a
rook to A7 and Knight to E5 all in one
turn but the problem is Rook A7 invites
Bishop C5 with Tempo Against The Rook on
A7 could MBL be contemplating an
exchange sack on E7 I don't think that
works but maybe it offers some practical
chances no you lose the knight in the
end of the line
um if I can show that real fast let's
bring up a board Bishop C5 maybe this is
what Carlson is calculating take Stakes
Queen E5 okay looks like White's got
some counter play but in comes the rook
and then in comes the queen and you have
to play G3 you give up the Knight on F3
and uh you are down a rook so Bishop C5
it looks like a good move maybe MBL is
just gonna play a combo of like Rook B7
here and maybe this is what Magnus is
trying to to puzzle out Robert let's go
back to the live board Magnus is still
deciding on his move and he's down to 30
seconds yeah it's a big choice because
Bishop C5 you might even win the F2 Pawn
with Rook D1 check the King has to go
away but he plays G5 what a choice here
basketball oh my gosh Queen 65. yeah
give me the center give me the pawn gift
me the pawn and Bishop C5 is gonna hurt
and once the bishop comes out Jen it's
gonna be a very nasty position of her
Carlson for MBL that is a Magna
yeah well this is really unpleasant
Bishop C5 goes right after oh this move
oh
he's going for the B2 Pawn Bishop B7
Bishop F6 that's how calmly he plays
right no Bishop C5 no drastic moves
total control over the game look at the
extent of his dominance here
it's ridiculous and the Knight on F3 is
completely corralled by the bishop on F6
no 95 jumps nothing of the sort Queen E2
no threat Rook B3 we're gonna bring your
queen to E8 then what you need to get
your team to the eighth rank as well but
Rook D1 there's even Rook takes B2
straight away
and queen E8 last ditch attempt by ml
it's not over 17 seconds for Carlson can
MPL complicate The Narrative if your
rookie 8 is coming but does he have a
threat rookie eight yeah King goes to H7
that's the problem look at this
as you would say filigree Precision
Queen B6 is available he goes C3
but G5 is not even hanging mvl has not
as you said been able to create a single
threat literally Carlson has positioned
his pieces in such a way that there
isn't even a way to create a threat if
you have three extra moves queen queen
comes in one
there's a threat
Rook H7 king of f8 unbelievable or King
G8 yeah whichever but you're gonna get a
new queen that is unbelievable
recognition that your king looks unsafe
so many of us mere mortal Grandmasters
would freak out you know try to protect
the H7 square and the queen G8 he says
good for you it's one check we're not
even playing three checks but that's a
good attempt for Maxime
that's a great attempt by Maxine but the
king is gonna hide away on EA don't go
King E7
after Knight's hd5 go King E8 so you can
block
so you can block the check on he's six
with his Bishop I'm choking on my words
and Maxime is at a dead end yeah Knight
E5 check is the same you know you can
just go King to E7 but there's Knight C6
check you have to watch out for Forks
but King E8 is played Queen E6 check
just to single check don't play Bishop
E7 that allows too many checks you can
bring your queen up to E7 but there's
Queen C8 so that's what Magnus and
Maxine were trying to figure out how do
we block the checks successfully I think
when all is said and done you might need
to play Bishop E7 to run your kingdom
too and we have the advantage of the
Ebola bar so we know Bishop E7 is
winning Magnus isn't as confident two
seconds he doesn't want to lose this
game oh and the confidence the
confidence to play this move with two
seconds on his clock
94.9 F6 is the main threat wow we made
them with 1.2 seconds he covers the F6
square and now with the king of seven
Queen F5 King G7 out of checks that's it
Queen E6 maybe keep trying if you're mvl
keep trying to check him no he resigns
he feels that there's no hope and you
can't really blame him can we bring that
board up again and you know do a little
bit analysis because that Knight E4 move
was so cheeky by Maxine versus the
ground I know he lost the game but it is
so easy to miss this Checkmate
configuration if you go C1 equals Queen
Knight F6 check king of fate and queen
G8 is mate the bishop could never take
the Knight it was pinned that was a
devilish Try by the French but Queen D4
such a calm defensive movement though
time Magnus realizes that these checks
on the eighth rank are not dangerous
because the king can just Escape either
to D7 or as in the game to F7 the guy is
totally Unstoppable doesn't matter how
much time he has does it matter how
tricky you are when he gets into these
zones I mean say your prayers say your
prayers because you're down by four and
this is a pivotal game Robert back we go
to the lifeboard back we go and Magnus
Carlson with a knight on B5 of Bishop
104 and black just played the move C7 to
C5 striking in the center so this has
been Maxine's idea throughout he's like
I don't like to play these passive
positions let me get a little bit more
active but that Knight on B5 Done Yet
such a thorn in Black side not only can
It Go to C7 if you're not an A6 moves
but if your Rook moves it just gobbles
up the A7 Pawn thank you very much and
normally in these positions you see
sometimes black playing Knight before
ultimately trying to get a six in
but mvl going Bishop C6 and queen D7
ultimately you're gonna have to solve
the problem of that Knight perhaps black
it even consider C4 to cut off the
connection between the bishop and the
Knight and sometimes white just leaves
the Knight on B5 and sacrifices that
pawn
and that might be what Magnus is
intending here against C4 I think C4 can
be met by Brook F1 to B1 say classic
move Rook F1 it was E4 just strikes in
the center he's just trying to collapse
Black's Pawn structure but Rook FB
wanted the same point here if D takes E4
thank you very much for the pawn on C4
if you take on B5 twice you're gonna be
in some trouble because now I have a
light Square Bishop you have a weak Pawn
on B3 your weak Pawn on B7 your knight
on A6 is just awkwardly placed so this
is looking really bad for maxim and he
desperately needs this one he is down
four points he cannot keep losing God it
seems that he's just playing natural
moves in this game and he's already much
worse staring down the barrel of what
could be a five-point lead this will be
the last game most likely of the
five-minute segment unless Magnus wins
this quickly which is looking pretty
likely right now he's got a big
advantage in the end game just because
his pieces are so well placed and
Black's position is riddled with holes
and weaknesses and deficiencies how bad
is it Robert I don't think it's actually
that bad but what a move that was
because the 9 A6 is loose Knight D4
looks like a double attack but the
bishop would safely slide back to B7 to
defend and as you're pointing at A5
that's the principled approach when you
have pawns on B6 and 8 and G6 fee and
Kettle structures you want to use your
Rook pod because you can develop your
rook in its place I know so many people
will say Let Me Go Rook A1 to D1 now
your Rook on F1 might go to D1 and your
A5 push allows your Rook on A1 to say oh
this open file is going to be beneficial
for me Magnus spoiled for choice and one
thing that we have been highlighting yet
another Ace on Mac upon magnus's sleeve
is the fact that he knows exactly when
to pause he just played five six moves
really quickly they were natural moves
now he senses that the structure has
transformed and he needs to act
precisely in order to keep the fire of
the initiative burning that's precisely
what he's doing he hasn't hesitated
Robert at times to take even two minutes
if that's what the position requires no
it is kind of funny that happens and
right now A5 looks so obvious so I
wonder what is the drawback of that move
I think Knight C5 might hold things
together for black oh I'm thinking about
a sack on A7
that looks very adventurous also you
might be considering with the move B2 to
B4 just to say your knight on A6 uh
where exactly is that going not to C5
anymore immediately before yeah right
now
to restrict the Knight love that move
and then the Knight could drop back to
D4 in the event the black tries to trade
the knights off it's in White's
advantage to keep as many minor pieces
on the board here as possible
Magnus thinking deliberating
um we've talked about a series of moves
Knight D4 upon A5 Pawn B4 Ian Rook after
D1 so which one will Magnus choose
that's the big question right now and
for Maxine this Knight on A6 that is not
a good night nights on the rim are dim
and this one it's a good morning doesn't
look very good
nice well played good pun thank you
thank you well it's a pretty good Pawn
on A5 which Magnus has finally put there
about a minute later than we thought he
would
and I'm pretty sure that Knight C5 I'm
pretty sure that Knight C5 is what he
was thinking intercepting the connection
between the bishop and B6
well there still might be B4 pushes
after Knight to C5 right just give me
the pawn on B6 he goes Knight to D4 oh
and Bishop B7 there might be a six and
then Knight C6 and Bishop D5 things like
that he is an artist Bishop B7 I'll show
this on the analysis board let's bring
it up quickly automatic move right looks
like black is fine A6 no black is not
fine drop the bishop back and is white
now going to go after this E4 Pawn no
Knight C6 and you can resign this is a
Forker rooski and you're also forking
the A7 Pawn that's how quickly that's
how close black is to collapse right now
and we're getting something similar in
the game Robert Maxine drops the bishop
back to D7 to control the C6 square but
in comes magnus's Bishop anyway
oh and Here Comes The Rook yeah give me
the a file the F7 Pawn is tender uh the
bishop on D5 dominating the bishop on D7
The Rook on A7 the best Rook on the
board and Bishop B8 the great move from
Maxime of a treaty move but the Rook
cannot stay on the seventh rank that was
huge
that was huge and Magnus missed that
move he might have forgot that the
bishop was defended that Knight on C5 is
the hero of Black's position but it's
not the end of the world for Magnus when
you're this well placed you can afford
to spend a Tempo or two that's not what
Magnus was looking for
although look at the control the boards
yeah fully open file D file is open but
there are minor pieces there the a file
is completely magnets for the taking but
this is one of those positions done yet
where it's aesthetically pleasing we
love the look of the Rogues great how do
we win this game what's the target we
played B4 at some point to kick the
Knight away and go up through B6 what is
the plan
it's all about carving infiltration
squares a retreating night move is on
the menu and the B6 Pawn is on the menu
as well
and Knight takes B2 that pawn is hanging
but C3 is not because the bishop can
slide back to D4 with check and then the
Nike go to C5 even for white and all of
a sudden White's pieces are jumping
forward it's looking awfully unpleasant
for maxim
but how exactly does Magnus coordinate
his pieces can he hunt for the Knight on
B4 okay Bishop covers the check Rook
infiltrates to A7 threats by the base in
full and this is looking nasty for the
Frenchman with three names Bishop takes
D4 Rook takes D7 olives on the f-step
oh can you get away with this
Rook D7
Bishop C3 Rook takes F7 that looks so
scary and then you can double on the
seventh Rank and normally that spells
trouble Robert may be black and park the
King on H6 and go rook h8 and there was
something there that Magnus didn't like
well maybe he just wants a doubles Rooks
anyway Rook B7 next hitting the Knight
on B2 oh Rook A1 to A7 give me the
seventh rank give me the F7 pawn and the
bishop can't really move from D7 there's
not a safe Square on the board and we
all have seven would fall right away and
the pressure has reached a Zenith it
looks like MBL can hold things together
according to the eval bar but neither of
the players knows what the evaluation is
there's tactics everywhere rookie seven
maybe was the move but there were Knight
C6 related problems NBL defending from
behind so Rook B7 what is the drawback
is there some kind of maybe temporary
psaccharides of Rook takes C3 and Rook
D3 something like that at least when you
see pieces in the same line there's a
rook ready to meet them and this by the
way is the final game of the five plus
one time segment it's official the
problem with Rook takes C3 and Rook D3
is that there's Knight C6 but I know you
were just illustrating the concept maybe
you can drop the bishop back to E8 at
some point not as long as the Rook is on
the seventh rank because then you're
running into 96 check but when you've
got this amount of tactics it's just so
easy to blunder and Magnus just keeps
intensifying and keeps tightening the
screws can he convert this into the full
point though Here Comes rookies
three okay and the Knight drops back for
defense okay he goes to C5 to protect E4
and the bishop all at once that's good
news but what's Black's next move can
black actually make a single move
I think Bishop B8 might be possible
since E6 is now protected good point so
can you play C4 to protect your bishop
and then once Bishop eighths played you
swap Rooks away Rook C7 to get rid of
that Knight great call and that's
exactly what the doctor ordered
ah
gosh this is so hard to defend king of
Fate Rook F6 uh so you can't really move
your king uh Rook moves from C8 to B8
there might already be Knight C6 tactics
to distract the bishop and win the F7
Pawn this looks really tough for black I
feel like it's a zuke's wrong I feel
like this is the point in the game where
the players are gonna go like H5 H4 and
then mvl is going to start thinking
again
throw in just any old move because you
don't have many
you don't and you can see him you're
taking his time he's still a minute up
on the clock but you're not gonna win
the game just with a Time Advantage we
have seen Magnus handle these end games
exquisitely even with two seconds on the
clock much less 20. is Knight C6 a
threat in some positions right if Bishop
takes Rook takes F7 check and then you
win a pawn so he goes King AJ giving up
the episode and that's the best move
apparently Bishop takes H3 maybe in
response
okay Bishop H3 is possible but then
there's oh wow I guess you get away with
I think Rook trade on d8 and Knight c65
D1 check so he goes Bishop D5 back the
King on h8 by the way might get
checkmated you can hop around to G5 then
you're delivering a mate
yeah you're hanging by a thread if
you're Maxine but we gotta take our hats
off Maximus doing a phenomenal job of
holding this together and so far he has
repelled every one of magnus's attempts
he might go back to B8 Bishop takes E4
is on the docket here as well
if your Rook moves off the back rank
then Rook C7 and your knight is
overloaded it gets kicked off C5 you
lose the bishop on D7 so The Rook has to
stay in contact with the C8 square if
you're maximum
can Magnus get him down on the clock I
think if Maxim has 10 seconds here he
doesn't survive and that's what it's
heading toward every single move Maxim
has to avoid 600 different tactics and
blunders King G3 and maybe G5 just to
keep the king out he was E3 here wow
because Rook takes you through his check
but now the pawn trade is obviously in
Black's favor the Knight can re-maneuver
to E5 but then the C Pawn is gonna
hurdle forward toward promotion yeah
just move your king away there watch out
for 95 to G4 by the way that was almost
Checkmate 95 could be a Checkmate threat
Magnus backpedaling I think mvl is the
closest he has been all end game long to
making the draw
he is for sure and if Max isn't careful
three seconds by the way he could find
himself victim to some kind of attack I
think Rook C5 forces it and we're gonna
get a liquidation here
oh my gosh what a defensive effort by
Maxine he's still down by four
but that was an important game to not
lose a very important game to hold and
that was extremely impressive and I
think that most anyone would have lost
that position he showed Hikaru Nakamura
level of Defense there
he most certainly did and at this point
neither side can make any progress so a
draw is imminence and it is the final
game of the five plus one so it's not
like they're wasting time for they're
just making a draw by repetition Magnus
Carlson leaves this time segment with a
four-point lead you see the Frenchman
with three names Maxine Russia La Graf
the reigning world of Blitz Champion he
is not thrilled to be in his position
and he just leaves the room probably
taking a stretch but Dania down four
points what does he need to change to
get back in this match
it's a nasty score it's a bit of a
catastroph no denying that but MBL has
to take the Silver Lining away from that
side when he has won a game and Robert
that's saying a lot considering Magnus
Carlson's form he's had a fantastic
defensive effort just now he's had some
games with good positions out of the
opening so he has to invest some time in
figuring out exactly what he's going to
do against magnus's D4 Knight F3 and bd2
setup he has to try to squeeze these Ry
Lopez positions with white maybe deviate
from that Marshall which Magna seems to
have down pat and obviously avoid one
move blunders in the three-minute
segment you cannot afford a single other
peace blunder like the one he had early
in the match you certainly cannot
otherwise that seemingly inevitable
matchup between Magnus Carlsen and
Hikaru Nakamura for the speed Chess
Championship here on chess.com that
would be likely so Maxime needs to
gather himself he needs a fight back get
some victories here and there but you
know everyone out there if you're
watching if you want to become a
chess.com Champion you have your chance
with the new year around the corner get
ready for the 2023 daily Chess
Championship starting January 1st five
thousand dollars in cash prizes are up
for grabs this year so don't miss your
chance to enter this tournament and
prove your daily chess prowess drop the
command daily Champs in the chat for
more info on the tournament and with
that we'll be right back when we turn
three minute plus one second increment
type Patrol begins in this matchup
between Magnus Carlson and Maxine Russia
lagrav
[Music]
so I first learned about ill Cafe
through my buddy Aaron he was like Hey
me and a group of fellas meet at this
Cafe downtown on Sundays and we play
chess there it'd be really cool if you
could stop by and hang out with us and
you know just feel the vibe and so I
showed up
and it was a nice bike I was like yo yo
Cafe is pretty ill
[Music]
egal
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is brewing oh my goodness there are no
more checks within the Tempest the best
have come to test their skills and brave
the storm
for some this is familiar ground oh my
gosh
oh my gosh oh my God what a tactic
where's the mate though I don't know but
it's gotta be there oh my God
the battles will be electric
the moves will be fast
learning to see Bishop C7 oh my God the
stakes will be high oh
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
welcome back everybody to the speed
Chess Championship semifinals this
matchup is Magnus Carlson your world
champion against Maxine Buster legrov
your world Blitz champion and before we
dive into the numbers I want to thank
everybody for tuning in we are about 5
000 people away from 1 million
subscribers on YouTube so if you're
viewing there please hit the Subscribe
button your viewership is very important
to us but Dania we are in the midst of
this matchup it is Magnus Carlsen with a
big lead but as we look at the chess.com
Blitz insights Maxine he's the much more
experienced player he's played nearly
double the games on the site as has
magnets and one of Maxine's greatest
strengths as the bottom stat reveals is
his time management he loses
exceptionally rarely by flag he's a fast
player in classical chess as well and
he's pretty fast with the mouse he wins
a good share of games on the clock as
well as does Magnus but I have to point
out Robert that if you look at magnus's
Blitz Games from two years ago it's a
completely different person he has
greatly improved his ability in time
scrambles and he's improved his mouth
skills so Magnus might lose more games
by flag but we saw him in the five
minute segment handling every time
Scramble with surgical Precision yeah
and Magnus Carlson has been back on
chess.com playing in title Tuesdays
winning some of them leaving some you
know nibbles for the rest of them of
course Hikaru Nakamura has the most
title Tuesday wins but right now Maxine
versus he looks like he's praying and
well he needs to pray to the chess Gods
out there because Magnus Carlson is
unforgiving he's been punishing Maxime
left and right even when Maxime has a
good position it feels like things still
are not going his way but with the you
know new type control genre he needs to
reset he has an opportunity here he did
defeat Magnus in this High Patrol two
years ago it's going to be hard to storm
out the entire four-point lead in the
segment but as I always say when you're
down big going into a segment you got to
try to have it at least bring it down to
two at least make it so that you can
come back in the first half of the
bullet but whatever you do don't let
this match get away from you in the
first couple of games and that's
precisely what Magnus Carlson is going
to try to do Robert he's going to try to
bring the hammer down in these first 20
minutes or so well look at this opening
C4 from Maxime he's changing up his
opening play he doesn't want to uh just
be a Target that Magnus has successfully
been pairing off so he plays this
opening we see a fiancado bishop on both
diagonals for white the bishop B2
staring down to E5 Pawn which is well
defended the bishop on G2 that's the
PowerHouse piece right Donya in these
English lines the bishop has the length
of diagonal at its disposal yeah both
Bishops are kind of powerhouses and the
bishop on G2 there's a lot of traffic on
the other diagonal right now but
eventually the Knight can move away from
F3 and if the Knight on C6 is eliminated
maybe with an exchange sacrifice then
we're saying a completely different tune
a very alert response by Magnus Rook
takes C6 Robert was actually a huge
threat there it's so easy to overlook
that as well because you think
everything is nice and tidy but F6
creating a pawn chain E5 is well
defended and sometimes black plays the
move Knight to D4 and we may very well
see that to open up the E file because
if Knight D4 e takes the E2 Pawn is a
backwards Pawn but for now Magnus
Carlson is pairing off the initial
threats he didn't allow B4 he plays
Queen D7 to prevent any sort of exchange
attack on C6 at least for the time being
but there still may be one done it Rook
takes CC oh absolutely it's not always
out of the question and it's a super
common idea in the Sicilian what we're
talking about here is essentially a
reverse Sicilian that's what the English
opening is so a sacrifice on C6 has to
be considered on every mode I wouldn't
do it here necessarily and the other
thing that disturbs me about mbl's
position is that this B Pawn is very
tender so you can't play the typical
maneuver 94 Knight C5 maybe you can
compromise and put the Knight on C4 but
yet again I think not only has Magnus
solves his opening problems I think
Maxime is the one who has to struggle
goal to keep the balance Knight D5 here
is a simple move and that forces the
bishop back yeah you move Knight C4
because it doesn't wasn't appealing
because it closed the C5 but said he
goes Knight to E4 if Knight takes C3
give me your Bishop after Rook takes you
three the C file remains open the Knight
is going to C5 in all likelihood black
is gonna have to part with his dark
Square Bishop as well but as you're
highlighting here that black strikes in
the center it goes queen of seven going
after the B3 Pawn still a decent
position for black even if not the
optimal move but the point is once white
tries for Knight C5 B3 is loose and also
that frees up the E4 Square so black can
play E5 to E4 if at night we're not
blocking the pawn and if you try to
defend uh the night the pawn with Knight
F to D2 you're allowing the Knight to
jump into D4 with rather devastating
effect and even if you don't end up
losing E2 what you might allow black to
do is push the pawn up to C6 and take
the sting out of White's bishop and be
all sacrificing the pawn is he intending
Rook C5 to B5 here is he still flirting
with an exchange sacrifice Robert the
eval bar seems to approve of his play
but what is the follow-up I think Rook
B5 looks pretty decent because if you
play Knight to D2 attacking the bishop
and going after 96 exactly the very safe
and sound Bishop D5 Retreat there are no
problems there for black so 92 doesn't
work which leaves Rook E5 as the
alternative and after Rook B5 well the
bishop B3 is actually not threatened so
maybe black has enough time to defend B7
with Rook to B8 as you're highlighting
here but that does look a little bit odd
so you have to be very careful here if
you're Magnus Carlson absolutely and
queen B2 is In The Same Spirit it does
get black and Tempo which you can use to
push the pawn up to A4 but then the
conversation about Knight D2 has to be
reopened because the bishop on B3 is
immobilized as long as B7 remains
undefended of course our old friend
Knight C6 to D4 white always has to
reckon with that move whenever he moves
the Knight away from F3 Bishop D5 by
Magnus using tactics Robert to protect
the B7 Pawn
and there's an argument he made for a
move like Queen takes B7 Knight D4 Rook
takes D5 and exchange sacrifice because
once you win B7 C7 will fall next uh I
don't know if I would go for that here
then move E2 to E4 or kicking the bishop
back and then Queen takes B7 because
then your knight is loose and there's no
pressure of the bishop against the queen
on B7 so E4 looks like a worthy move
however the downside is the D3 pawn it
becomes a permanent Target and maybe
you'll get C7 but you'll lose D3 the
bishop on G2 as you were just
highlighting doesn't look so great it's
a really big Choice both options look
quite promising but you can make an
omelette without breaking some eggs I
think MBL should decide on e4 look at
the clock though he's down to 25 seconds
one would think that Magnus is normally
the one down by a minute in these types
of positions but he's turned it around
in the first game of the three-minute
portion Rook to B5 a move we thought
might have been played earlier he plays
it now he's trying to induce B6 which
Magnus is not gonna play because then
there are tactics The Rook takes D5 and
the Knight was loose speaking of the
night it moves back and undevelops
itself in order to protect B7 that's one
of the moves that you say when you're
just glossing over the game you don't
really give that its full credit Knight
B is a phenomenal move you save your
opponent C7 and your b-pawn and now that
make you jump out Knight A6 to C5 at
some point watch out still for ideas
revolving on a rook takes D5 sacrifice
the light squares are compromised but
look at Maxim's clock and look at
magnus's Magnus as you were just saying
up a lot of time here he can figure
things out maybe King h8 could be a
prude move at some point I just don't
think it's necessary right now and it's
a Magna style move I think evio's only
obvious Queen side idea is to push that
pawn up to A5 keep breaking apart
Black's Queen side keep inducing we can
businesses love the speed with which MBL
played A4 and the clock situation is
starting to balance out here
yeah a bit in Knight C5 A5 Knight B3
there might be an exchange SEC on B3
you're on D5 right away so you have to
be really careful about these Knight
jumps and the Knight and A6 it really
wants to improve Knight to C5 but with
A5 on the docket I'm not so sure it
works out so maybe move the bishop away
from D5 but as you said A5 comes really
fast Magnus counter strikes in the
center with E4 now the D file is open
and whites work on B5 is kind of out of
commission who is going to Prevail and
magnets
watch out for the fork he goes Rook to
B4 and now the bishop can move out the
way and E2 is a target oh and it's just
a problem that you can never really take
on B6 because of that fork MBL trying to
simplify but it looks
oh and The Rook takes D6 exactly but
he's just going saying my Pawn structure
is healthier and that is true so white
has an advantage here oh
Roblox
Rook B6 what a move
yeah he's up a pawn oh Magnus in trouble
here and on the clock it's about to even
up
I can play Rooks Rook C2 can be played
on the next move white can stabilize
pretty easily here seven seconds for
Magnus Rook C2 and option goes Queen B4
Rook D4 okay you can take it you wanted
yeah Rook B8 type of stuff exactly
all right now it's a 50 50 game no risk
for MBL he can keep pushing he should be
able to win this yeah Magnus a good
Defender but this is not pleasant at all
Knight F5 coming your way right now
grooves maybe G6 should be considered
there's that Knight and black
desperately wants to trade Knights the
knights come off the drawing task is not
easy but easier but with the Knight on
H4 it's in the night rerouting itself at
some point look at the trades happening
I think Magnus is making progress
he certainly is
he doesn't want to play G5 though
because that allows the knights joke
going to the F5 oh say that again come
again something happened with my
headphones there well you got to trade
yeah no not totally over but I think
it's a draw I I think at this point it
should be pretty easy yeah because you
can't create a past Pawn
dude that was crazy was it ever even in
doubt it's almost like he was never
worse to begin with oh but yeah a lot of
Pawn end game
it's still a draw though I think he's
lucky because I don't think he saw he
missed it oh he definitely missed it
King G7 I think is the move but will you
find it with one second okay and now
King F7 King D4 King E6 lose
and he has opposition
he does but where does he go now back to
86 so he can meet King F4 with King E6
Magnus just in command of these end game
principles to a T
I want to say goodness and I feel like
Max is gonna shake his head he always
seems to be shaking his head always I
believe overlooked Knight f4check and
he's fortunate that was still a drug but
that was excellent technique great
defense from the world champion Magnus
Carlson well in the words of capablanca
good players are always lucky Magnus
always seems to have uh uh you know
Maxine seems to always have the shorter
end of the stick in these time scrambles
and that was a big big chance for the
Freshman for the Freshman he is a
freshman he's also a Frenchman to cut
into the lead and as it stands Carlson
keeps a four point advantage and another
English Carlson says I like that idea I
thought you were going Bill Walton on me
for a second you know the conference of
Champions you know just give me
everything we can handle here but in all
seriousness that was an amazing display
of Defense from Magnus but Maxime is
showing he's going to put up a fight he
is not just gonna roll over because he's
down four points in this match and
Magnus taking one out of Maxine's book
playing C4 systems English systems and
enjoying a spatial Advantage with B4 to
come and you can't map out a strategy
that's going to allow you to beat Magnus
all you can do is try to get complicated
positions in every game by the way B5
and Knight H4 looks like an interesting
way to try to secure the bishop pair
maybe there are tactics there with
Bishop H3 we'll get to it in a second
you just got to get those types of
positions every single game and maybe
some of them are going to go your way
now E4 a very committal decision by
Magnus help me make sense of this
position who's better and why white
definitely is better because white
controls the pawn breaks because where's
Black's activity Where Are You Gonna
spring free your pieces the Knight on A5
is offside why can you play Bishop D2 he
goes Bishop B2 but I was gonna say you
go with Bishop d2 move your knight play
A4 just claim a space advantage on the
queen side but E6 takes away the D5
Square as you're indicating so now it's
coming up with an actual plan as black
might strike with D5
yeah you like to say that the side which
controls the pawn breaks holds the
positional Advantage white was holding
the pawn brakes now with D5 on the
horizon White's Pawn structure is really
really flimsy if D5 breaks up this Pawn
chain Robert White's gonna be riddled
with Pawn weaknesses as a result Magnus
has to do something pronto and he plays
calmly Queen C2
maybe there's D5 Square for your knight
it looks threatening but don't forget
about the knight in A5 because if you
could win Knight E5 to C6 you would have
just one on the spot but the Knight on
A5 covered as you put on Knight E2 we're
getting into a king's Indian attack
style position right where White's gonna
go H4 bring that knight from C3 to the
king side and oh this is Black's Frozen
this is phenomenal decision making by
Magnus he doesn't panic he doesn't do
anything crazy he just takes the sting
out of the move D5 he realizes that what
that move really accomplishes is it puts
pressure on C4 so he says hey I'm gonna
put my queen on C2 so that it defends
the pawn and now I'm gonna move my
knight back and while I'm at it I'm
going to improve that Knight as you said
King's Indian attack style might
supplement that with h2h4 it's amazing
to me that A6 is like some kind of huge
mistake it was minus 0.4 or something
and now it's plus 0.4 what is the
difference and what black swell up is
going to be perhaps opening the a file
was a big mistake you pointed the B6
Pawn but if the a file opens up well
then The Rook goes A1 and Bishop to C3
so you you are absolutely right the B6
Pawn is a long-term Target but I just
feel like this position is easy for
white to play and in the World Cup a
year ago Sam Shanklin here he found
himself in a position like this and it
didn't end well for him it did not and
White's got a bunch of easy moves as
you're saying you could get checkmated
here Knight E2
G1 and Carlson for the second game in a
row makes a move to undevelop his Knight
and what a move it is Robert the knights
are now connected and you can play
rookie 4 and try to extend your
dominance over the center
and F3 is defended he brings the Rook to
E4 there's some tactical shot somewhere
otherwise Knight E8 to D6 but then Queen
E2 protects the Knight and F3 another
time but there's a feeling that White's
pieces here are not very stable they
look very nice but you have to watch for
Knight takes C4 you have to watch for
these Maneuvers but I don't see anything
concrete for mvl as of yet
nor do I so Maxime he sells a little bit
of a leave the clock
immediately goes to PL what is happening
Bishop o4 maybe was a more prudent way
to stop Knight D6 yeah or Bishop G5 was
available what whoa any blundered a
piece he blundered a piece Magnus
Carlsen is human he's human he just
blundered a piece Maxine caused problems
in the f file and the diagonal and look
at Magnus sitting back in his chair he
does not look happy and Maxime is simply
up a piece you better win this game
you have to win this you are morally
obligated uh to exploit the gifts that
the world champion gives you because he
is not going to give you that many of
him he might give you one the entire
match but look at the eval bar it's a
piece ahead oh oh wait a queen F3 queen
of three oh Queen F3 but it's a thread
now Queen E8 is a huge threat
oh my goodness this ain't over
Rook after all the activity for white
but rookie ate good moves oh Magnus
still holding on though he needs his
King off of G2 if he's any chance in
this game his King needs to get off and
play Knight G5 phenomenal move by mvl
using the queen side to his advantage
and bringing the Knight potentially over
to D2 to strain the Knight on F3
yeah where's the bishop going Bishop B2
ugh Rook takes up six you can just take
oh he took it that way I thought he was
gonna take it to Knight T3 it's just
winning well
is it or is it the B5 Pawn is awfully
impressive the Knight now stuck in place
you don't want to drop C5 and give away
two passers and let's not forget that
white is up a Pawn on the king side so
essentially one Pawn for a bishop the
bishop not very helpful right now and
the B Pawn gonna go up the board oh my
God
and why is just attacking and not only
is the bishop not helpful Robert it's
also harmful it's creating problems with
the back rank Magnus picks up another
pawn and he's gonna restrain wax passer
with 94. he might not even be that much
worse here he might even win this game
like in his pawns again no no no no no
no don't you don't you speak that
language I'm just looking you're
absolutely right it reminds me of the
match yesterday between nihal and
Nakamura where Hikaru was in trouble and
then suddenly The Avenge went from plus
four to plus two to plus one and then
when you allow your opponent back in the
game bad things happen oh and you can't
take on B5 because of the Perpetual rook
d8 and the Knight toggles between G5 and
F7 that is absurd so Rook B5 is
immediately a draw by repetition and I
don't think that Maxime is gonna win
this game anymore 55 you actually could
lose it I'm gonna co-sign your point as
long as white keeps the pawn on B5 alive
the Knight has the anchor spot on G5
it's so easy to miss a fork here it's
easy to let the beep on slip by
obviously Maxim shouldn't lose this he
might even still win but it's basically
a three result game at this point it is
indeed and now Rook D6 comes to mind as
an option just to go for the G6 Pawn he
goes 94 back why change anything and if
you swap knife for Bishop maybe that's
where black has some chances so that's
why Magnus keeping is not on the board
I'm gonna Hazard against that Magnus is
also keeping the knights because he
wants to keep winning chances alive he's
hoping that MBL might miss a fork or
blunder another pawn and Magnus is
playing this very ambitiously Rook C6
can you get away with that because if
you take on b596 check watch out good
call Magnus is calculating just that I'm
positive but he goes for Rook C7
attacking the Knight hitting the king
Rook C6 now all right they might no he
goes for a trade
and each Pawn the H Pawn is the wrong
Pawn Dania so let's keep that in mind if
a rook trade you need to trade the G6
part of the board you make a draw what a
call by Magnus he sees that he's gonna
go G4 yes wait he should have done it on
the previous move but it still might be
a draw yeah I guess you can't make
progress the king just shuffles in F2
and G2 and the better you should go
after the G3 Pawn can you try King H3
then white plays King F3 and you got to
be careful of your Maxine King F3 same
thing King H3 yes unreal seven King back
to H2 G4
King D5 G4 he's gonna make it G4 now and
it's a draw unreal unbelievable save I
mean what does this guy what can't this
guy do but this is why I bring it up
time and time again bishop and the H1
Square do not match that means it's a
draw even though you're up a healthy
Four Points of material wow what a hold
from Magnus Crossing blunders a full
piece Donya how do you beat this guy
that was a prophetic call by you the
game indeed ends with a pawn of the
wrong color I have no answers for you
Maxima's no answers for you and he's got
to produce answers pretty quickly
because he just had two golden
opportunities to cut into this lead and
God knows how many more of them you're
gonna get the answer might actually be
zero well if he plays the way he did
against Fabiano caruana Magnus Carlson
just seems unbeatable and he literally
did not lose a game in that match right
now he has lost the game earlier I think
it was the third game overall this match
and Maxine plays rookie one we have this
interesting Spanish position where the
pawn it juts out on E5 it's maybe
overextended but black doesn't have room
for the bishop C8 it's stuck behind
pawns the black piece are a little
awkward as well this is an old lion it's
a temporary peace sacrifice so don't
lose your mind here Maxine sees that the
bishop hangs he's preparing the move
Queen G4 and Robert as far as I remember
the move here is D7 D5 you gotta get
this Knight off the board ASAP
and he plays it so Magnus Carlson
remembering this old variation and he
takes D6 on passant no and so we see
Bishop takes C6 and you either move as
possible you take on a five here Bishop
takes D5 it looks like there are a lot
of hanging pieces but Bishops either
this bishop F7 check and that feels like
you know white might get the upper hand
I don't know but the open file there the
Knight jumping into D3 I feel like black
is a pretty big initiative there I think
Magnus is going to snap that pawn off he
might also go C7 C6 that's a slightly
Tamer move
and maybe that forces the bishop onto an
awkward Square let's see I'm just glad
you didn't say it was a Tamer or a job
up move because that's a pawn
[Laughter]
you're making me say puns now but C6
looks really strong because you kick the
bishop away once the Queens get traded
C2 is loose and so your down opponent is
black but you're very likely to recoup
that material
indeed good word oh are you hoop your
investment look at why it's minor pieces
wait but the evil bar going higher and
higher for white it's an extra Pawn
because you can develop your pieces and
black lacks the uh the offensive
Firepower to actually exploit the lack
of development here is that a good way
of looking at this I think so Knight D2
Knight F1 we've seen this before and I
can also go to B3 if you want to offer
some trades black is going to be down
upon now I think Magnus would like to
play Rook D7 Rook d8 as quickly as
possible but he keeps throwing in these
Queen side pawn moves and they're
confusing for me just because well his
play mesmerizes me and I'm just trying
to figure it out on the fly but it looks
like you're right he wants my A4 maybe
even A3 to carve out some dark squares
or bring his Rook up to A5 it's also a
possibility
he's grabbing some space he's making a a
low risk High reward kind of move the
problem is that if you give MBL a couple
of Tempe he's going to bring the Knight
over to G3 he might even play F4 F5 if
you're not careful and once the bishops
come out your compensation will begin
evaporating Magnus though he's totally
unconcerned he's like I don't care I'm
just chilling on the queen side I think
he's going to Care in a couple moves
because Bishop G6 F4 you have to play
Bishop H4 an awkward move just to stop
the pawn push to F5 that is not
comfortable and if you play Bishop E6 as
he just did well it feels like now white
is better protected the bishop on that
diagonal is hitting the C2 Pawn now the
light Square Bishop for white is also
free to evacuate the D1 Square envel
very alert stopping halting the progress
of Black's a pawn bishop B3 is coming
next and I think the initiative for
black has fizzled out
it certainly has I mean you're just down
upon and Max's claim is that well it's
only one Pawn I'm gonna play H4 then
Knight E4 we'll see some trades and a
pawn down Rook end game likely not the
end of the world if you're thinking
about this from magnus's perspective
after the previous game it feels like
he's up material
okay Bishop D4 good move E5 is super
well defended
what traits do you think black wants
first of all I'll point out that C5 is
innocuous the bishop has a nice parking
spot on C3 that merely opens the
diagonal for the other Bishop what
trades does black want I was gonna say
trade the dark scored Bishops because
White's light squared Bishop is to use
an expression I've never used before
biting on granite mvl says no such luck
and now the Knight is gonna jump into E4
with access to these two very unpleasant
outposts
yeah and the Black Knight doesn't have a
similar Outpost that's why the trade on
C5 would have helped black the C5 square
is kind of an outpost because white
can't kick it with a pawn at least not
very easily so Bishop C3 a good Retreat
for maxim he is well ahead in the clock
magazine under 40 seconds right now
things are not looking easy for him I'm
a broken record but here's a third
chance in a row for mvl to slice into
this lead and is the third time the
charm or is Magnus gonna pull out yet
another save with low time on his clock
he doesn't care what the clock situation
is it's like he's totally unaffected
Robert yeah it's unbelievable I could
see him making move like Maxine Rook a
to B1 what a funny looking move please
PC but that's a little too obvious right
you're telegraphing your plan and the
bishop before it doesn't have to capture
on C3 but in all you know all across the
board here we see that white with the
extra Pawn E5 the Knight can come into
D6 or to F6 with check black does need
to figure out a plan but look at the
clock all of a sudden things are getting
closer to even on time we've seen this
storyline before Maxine trades and plays
C3 and now the Black Knight does finally
have not really an outpost but a very
juicy Square on C4 Maxine though he
beats him to the punch will black play
Knight C4 anyway who benefits in the
event of a nitrate I'm not sure Robert
there's also Rook A5 we mentioned that
possibly hurry earlier and it goes after
the E5 Pawn also right D5 square and if
that Knight is traded from D6 The Rook
will slide to B5 and pressure B2 so it
looks like Maxime still even on the
clock right now but this is a bad trend
for him it is and magnus's decision to
bring the pawn to A4 is looking
increasingly prophetic he's Frozen
White's Pawns in place they are now
immovable targets and they are easy to
attack he switches his eyes to the E5
pawn and if that pawn disappears black
might be better now it's pretty
incredible E5 is dropping you may get B7
but a black Brook's gonna land on E2 and
we also talk with this the activity is
worth material deficit and I think he
can safely take this Pawn on E5 he wants
otherwise white plays F2 to F4 and Good
Luck winning a pawn with that pawn chain
and Magnus jumps on the opportunity
train and comes the Knight to C4 from a
practical perspective I have no doubt in
my mind that black is firmly in the
driver's seat mvl trying to bail out he
oh that's a good move Knight takes C4 to
C1 Bishop takes A4 he he doesn't it
barely works out because rookie won't
check YouTube there's no Bishop C6 check
because the Rook covers the square and
now Rook C8 check is important he goes
Rook D4 to keep D5 controls this should
be a draw Rook A1 Knight C5 be careful
because Rook takes A3 D3 is available to
White you walk yourself into a pin so
black still has a little something to
prove four seconds Worth to do he paves
the way into Bishop D5 whatever now The
Rook swings over to A5 as he targets the
a pawn don't take it though yeah I don't
think he could take there he goes Bishop
E6 a white remains Maxine could play
this without any risk I don't know we've
seen crazy things happen I think Magnus
should hold this together but you're
absolutely right if one second find a
way oh my gosh he got down to one second
on the clock
this is playing with fire a couple pre
moves there to build up some clock if
the king leaves the king side black will
play Move G5 at some point so that's the
same is making progress
here comes the a-bon he's kicking up
into D4 the king's gonna help out he
plays G flowing up King left he's
pulling a Magnus right now Magnus
desperately trying to carve out some
space on the king side but he's too late
he seems to be too late he might have to
sacrificed his Rook for the pawn or a
bishop for the pawns what he hopes for
and then win the F3 94. 94 was winning
the bishop oh my gosh he would have won
the Bishop from the spot Maxi needs to
find moves like that can't go to the C7
but a king can't promote so the king is
all the way up there you need the pawn
to get to A7 Magnus playing moves with
two seconds two points two seconds of
long 94-96 wins the bishop again and
this time he sees it
can be a five Pawn it's not over if he
takes A5 he might also win F3 Maxi ships
it back oh it's six seconds but he's
gonna I think his end game is losing but
can he go A6 I don't know don't repeat
A6 you just got to play for win here six
seconds for it next year first oh my
gosh King is gonna go back to F4 he he's
not finding the way
Rook F6 and then A7 broken step six
first no and he can play
he had the Intermezzo and he missed it
and now it's a draw the king is
shouldered this is an easy draw from
Magnus Carlson and Maxima Sherlock
should be beside himself because he just
needs a blockade the pawn we'll show you
this after the game concludes but that
is such a missed opportunity and we keep
saying it he needs to put Magnus away
and he is in disbelief disgusted with
the biggest Miss of the match can you
believe he choked that I don't know what
to say right now let's bring up that
game and show you exactly where mvl
missed the last win first of all Robert
he could have won a piece there with 94
check but forget about that what was
King takes A7 as late as move 74. Robert
you cannot miss this if you're unreal
you just it's not allowed no you cannot
miss wins like this and if he didn't see
the intermed so he could have started
with Rook F6 check and done the same
exact thing and won the game but he just
played too quickly he pre-moved I know
he didn't have much time on the clock
but this would have been a winning
position if he found Rook F6
we talk about the Hikaru effect what
about the Magnus effect your fingers
turn into thumbs your brain turns to
Mush when you're on a Time scramble
against the world champion and that was
a dagger of a game for mvl he now stands
much worse in the next game and if
Magnus wins this that will be a massive
two-point swing at precisely the worst
moment to allow it for MBL cannot
believe that just happened I mean I
can't either to not win that game must
be really devastating but Maxime he's
trying to focus but his position is bad
four pawns for white in the fourth rank
Tonya not good
not good and this is going to be eating
at him for the rest of the match at
least five percent of his brain is not
going to be firmly dedicated to
castigating himself see didn't say the
wrong word there but for missing the win
in that position unfreaking believable
it must be so unbelievable I mean it
just Maxime is really in each individual
game playing neck and neck with Magnus
it's not about the level of Play It's
just in critical moments he just seems
to be off and Magnus Carlos in the other
hand he is able to punish his opponents
in all types of positions variety is the
spice of life but unfortunately for
mag's opponents variety still leads to
victory for him and right now look at
this Dania he's got the bishop pair he
is The Rook active he's got a three on
two on the queen side this is looking
very tough for Maxine buster legroute
now just to finish that point in most
circumstances I'm willing to give Magnus
full credit for creating the
circumstances for displaying that insane
defense of resilience but in that case
it was all Maxime Maxime did that to
himself in the previous game
it's a shame and this position does not
feel fun
on B2 the bishop on G2 both staring
across the board black is on the
defensive and queen C for such a lovely
little Magnus move he wants to play yeah
he's protected upon zero he can even
take on F6 take on e4 go up a pawn I
know opposite color Bishops so that
gives black some drawing chances but
that probably still gives white some
serious winning chances I mentioned the
first 20 30 minutes of the three-minute
segment we could have been singing a
very different tune if Maxime had won
even one of the previous three games at
this point it looks like a five-point
lead is inevitable but with opposite
colored Bishop still on the board
there's always going to be a fair share
of chances yeah and white can
immediately play B5 and pawn to C6 the
bishop on G2 perfectly placed defending
the C6 Square so you can just say give
me the password look what Magnus does
and the engine doesn't like it what do
you think instead of creating a pass
Pawn I'm Gonna Keep Your Target in place
that is a long-term liability and
magnets can slowly improve Rook F4
Bishop D5 create threats and it's a
major concession in the sense that B4 B5
is no longer all that effective but
Magnus says I'm going to attack that
pawn with my pieces I don't need my
pawns I'm going to try to build a
battery on the long diagonal love the
way that mvl is defending actively
though and for the moment he's been
pushing Magnus away and Rook takes H4
wins back the pawn wow that's a big
oversight and a great find from Maxine
so he is clawing back he's not going to
just lose a bad position and now still
worse yeah he's worse but he's getting
activity he doesn't just trade pieces
he's just looking at the B7 Pawn as a
Target but if that Bishop for black gets
to D4 F2 is also something that needs to
have an eye kept on it great point and
it's easy to overpress here if you're
Magnus all of a sudden he's experiencing
major problems with his King Maxim could
throw that pawn on H4 and induce more
weaknesses he's trying to figure this
out
he trades and then plays H4 what happens
after Queen E4
it looks like it should remain level but
HG Queen G5 I think about positions like
this is that opposite colored Bishops
are good for the attacking side the bad
news for black is the opponent B7 is
stuck in a light Square so if you ever
trade the Queens you might just simply
lose in the spot but in terms of the
attack well look at this queen H4 Queen
H2 it's a paper tiger you love to use
that phrase it's just a single check
I think Maxine could have made a quick
draw there with Queen takes E4 and
Bishop C3 but instead he's trying to
keep chances alive he's been up on the
clock consistently throughout the first
half of this segment but at this point I
think the prudent thing to do is just
repeat moves yeah it's going to be a
draw here
Queen G5 forces it's the halfway point
here the players get a break and for
Magnus Carlsen he's caught a few breaks
in this time Patrol I I know he still
has this lead but the match score can be
a bit deceiving Maxima shiligrav has had
his opportunities Dania oh without
question Maxima has been pushing him
around Magnus blundering a piece uh in I
think that was the first game and then
the biggest opportunity came in the
previous game and finally Magnus was the
one in the driver's seat in this game
and a great save by Maxine so Maxime is
playing great chess the problem is that
the match score isn't reflecting it he
actually needs to deliver he needs to
keep this going keep the initiative
going but Robert I mean you just gotta
delivery you've got to convert these
into points yeah one at a certain point
there's no consolation prize right
getting good positions against Magnus is
not enough you need to win those games
we'll see if Maxine is able to do that
on the flip side of this break this is
the speed test Championship semifinals
Magnus Carlson versus Maxim Russia
lagrav
foreign
chess is great for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kid
is the safe parent-approved way for your
child to play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing which
has a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest bustles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
here to the speed Chess Championship
this match is Magnus Carlson against
Maxine Russia lagrav I'm Grandmaster
Robert Hess alongside me Grandmaster
Daniel naroditski and on behalf of
chess.com we want to thank all of you
we've crossed 55 000 viewers across the
platforms and we're nearing 1 million
subscribers on YouTube so please click
that subscribe button get us to 1
million that will be a very happy day
for us all but it is a happy day right
now for Magnus Carlson and the community
well they're probably pretty happy
because those of you who have filled out
your brackets 84 predicted Magnus Donya
it really has been all magnets thus far
at least in the scoreboard
it has indeed an mvl is just not getting
that vote of confidence in this matchup
and also not a lot of people predicting
this matchup in the first place I think
a ton of people thought Jana Palm Desi
don't forget that name that he would
make his way to the SEC finals but MBL
had an impressive path to get here but
Robert missed opportunity after missed
opportunity thus far in the first half
of the three plus one portion he had
three golden chances to win the game two
of them in completely winning positions
he had a piece up in one game he could
have been a rook up in the other and
instead he has not chipped away at this
lead at all and what a frustrating match
it must be for maxim he beat Jan
diplomacy the winner of the candidates
for second time in a row he beat the
chess.com Global Champion Wesley so but
now he's facing the big boss the world
champion the best player in chess for
over the last decade it is Magnus
Carlsen with C on the bracket the winner
of this match right now looking like
Magnus Carlson is to face Hikaru
Nakamura in Epic Championship Showdown
oh my goodness that is just going to be
we're going to need five speed belts to
be fast and like one on top of the other
whatever we get whether it's Nakamura
Carlson or even mvl puts up pulls off uh
what by now I think it's safe this era
would be the greatest comeback in SCC
history the way that this match was
going the plus side is that he's got
plenty of time in the three plus one
portion and I would say Robert that the
magic number for Maxime is three if he
can get just one more point off of
magnus's lead going to the bullet we
have seen several three-point comebacks
in the bullet segment thus far here we
go I think it's a good point though and
I I think we should reiterate that that
if Maxi can win just one game in this
time until he has a chance because well
the chest is sloppy right now you make
mistakes happen even Magnus Carlsen will
blunder in bullet he blundered in blitz
so I'm with you there that one game
needs to be won by Maxine just kind of
just barely and don't lose yeah
without being said but where you have an
Italian game Magnus backs the bishop to
A7 I just said it Robert so I just I
just said it okay you know I'm okay with
it when you say it as long as it doesn't
happen if you're a Maxine by Sheila
Grove look at this Dunya rerouting the
Knight Bishop on A7 oftentimes the pawn
is on A6 for black in this variation or
the pawn A5 you stop the pump push B2 to
B4 but you do give up that B5 Square it
may seem unimportant but often white
plays the move Bishop B5 in variations
but this structure has become
increasingly popular if you don't know
anything about this position you might
say hey I learned that when the pawn
reaches E6 like this it controls all of
the key Central squares it restricts the
993 so visually black is a good position
also black has the semi-open f file I
always prefer these positions from black
side but somehow the engine always feels
that that white is slightly better here
there is the move d4 but French style
there's the exchange sacrifice on F3
that you have to keep track of on every
move it's reminiscent of Rook take C3 a
couple of games that go for Maxim's
perspective there it is
I mean if this were bullet it would be
played instantly Magnus thought for a
little bit now Knight F4 comes with
Tempo things like that uh oh goodness
this doesn't look Pleasant oh your speed
belt is unfastened if your Maxime and
the roller coaster is shaking blacks
pieces are streaming into the king side
and the other night Robert let alone the
pieces already on the king side if the
other Knight appears on H4 the death
knells are gonna start to toll did you
see the evil bar by the way it like
stayed at like a like 0.7 for black and
then went down to 1.5 so the more depth
that the engine gains the better and
better it looks for black but I guess
Rook f8 was a misstep by Carlson because
they're King H1 now it's starting to
feel like well where's the follow-up
Knight E7 Knight G6 Knight H4 it's time
consuming and maybe white has time to
strike with D4 you need to get some
activity for yourself while you're
defending your king side you have to and
Maxime does just that great minds think
alike maybe get the queen out from F1
the problem with that is that there's
always going to be Queen H5 to H3 so for
the time being the queen on F1 is pegged
into place the Knight is jumping into H4
and Maxine doing everything he can to
keep his King side from falling apart
yeah but even though he's trying to
fight tooth and nail it looks so ugly
for that white king I mean right now
moves like Knight to H4 look very
pleasant I also want to kick the knight
from G4 it gets trapped if my queen
we're not there so Queen H4 by Pawn to
H5 where's your knight coming exactly
that's an amazing move because
automatically you would go Knight G6 to
H4 but Magnus stops at the drop about
switches on a dime and H5 is coming next
and Robert once the Knight is kicked
away it's gonna be kicked away to E3 I
think my steam has to move his Rook
Knight to H3 is going to acquire much
greater potency and it might even win
the game yeah because F2 and F3 will be
under attack right F2 was defended but
Knight H2 attacks it The Rook on f8
stares down F3 now Rook C3 does attack
C7 that could be a little bit rattling
for a player who's already down material
but I believe that Rook takes E7 isn't
actually that worrisome and Knight H3
with H5 to follow looks very strong and
if we bring up an analysis board real
fast I think you should start with
Knight H3 because if you play H5 if we
go down that line Knight H3 white has
the move Knight G2 looks like black wins
on the spot but no remember the queen is
hanging and here you actually have to
force the repetition with Knight H3 and
Knight F2 they're going down this line
exactly back we go to the lifeboard
Knight G2 is on the board and Magnus I
think just doesn't want to play for a
Winnie or just wants to make a draw or
will he play Queen F2 oh wow yeah he
could no he's gonna make a draw here and
I think it makes sense right we have the
evaluation off to the side of the screen
we don't have the moves but we can see
that our black is better Magnus like oh
this looks interesting I have some play
here but if I can force the draw at
minimum why not I have a four point lead
in this match which makes perfect sense
it's a sensible decision Magnus milking
some time off the clock I think he's
thinking about Queen F2 but probably
he's already decided to make the draw
he's just kind of pulling a Hikaru could
he play it moves like Queen E7 as well
just try to protect the C7 Pawn uh how
bad does it get for blood that's the big
question Magnus is asking himself
because if he Retreats his Queen he is
down exchange and then he doesn't have
an attack anymore so I think Knight F2
check feels like the smartest reply he
plays it and he also wastes a match
clock by deliberating or a little bit
there I wonder if we've ever had five
draws in a row in an SEC match and none
of these draws came for lack of trying
all of them were incredibly competitive
but nonetheless I think this might be I
don't even think we've had three draws
in a row
yeah no this but they're all those games
I mean they were really duking it out
and we see another ready system it'll
turn into an English in some of the
previous games uh but we see Mega's
castle and will he strike with move C4
here sometimes he'll strike with D4
instead and Magnus he's shown a
predilection this entire match for just
like avoiding mainstream Theory and I
really like that decision these types of
positions are rather theoretical though
there is Knight D4 to B5 and there's a
famous draw robber Knight B5 Bishop E6
I've made this straw before and then the
Knight drops back to D4 in turn forcing
the bishop back to see it of course
Magnus he wants a little bit more out of
the opening than that and these
positions oftentimes black tries to
figure out where to develop the Knight
here goes the D7 Knight C6 may have cost
black a pawn which is why he goes here
and Knight C5 not an outpost exactly as
we see here Bishop went to A3 Queen to
B3 no Bishop E6 for you if you take on
D4 with your Dark Sword Bishop your king
is unsafe so it means that for the time
being black has to spend some time
trying to push pawns and pieces the
bishop on C8 stuck at home I never
totally understand the appeal of these
types of positions from black side I get
that White's Queen Side Pawn structure
is damaged and if you can keep White's
initiative at Bay then eventually those
pawns can make their presence fill but
you see something interesting here I
thought Bishop E7 was a woman of course
oh Bishop A4 is the response already
threatening to win The Exchange so look
at that Magnus accidentally allowed the
bishop out of its cage on C8 and that is
good recognition for Maxime Maxime has
been sharp throughout the three minute
portion make no mistake he's played
excellent chess it's just in those time
scrambles that he's kind of lost his
mind a couple of times I think he's
probably slightly better and he's again
up 40 seconds on the clock I'm a broken
record he's got yet another chance can
he pull this one out he's played better
than Magnus has the three plus one I
feel pretty confident in that I mean
Magnus was down to peace in one game uh
there are other games where Max has been
in trouble is back against the wall but
Magnus does not go down without a fight
he bends but he does not break and right
now after this bishop A4 threat does he
move the queen away does he move his
Rook up to a square like D3 which looks
a bit awkward but might allow you to
double Rooks on the D file I'm not
entirely sure Knight B5 comes to mind I
feel like it's in the spirit of the
position white has to stay active that's
the only big advantage that white has is
better placed pieces but after Knight B5
you have to calculate obviously Bishop
takes B5 and queen takes C3 things get
very messy The Rook on A1 is always in
the crosshairs of Black's grundfeld
Bishop on G7 and Magnus goes for the
Hess approach Rook do you want a D3 now
Bishop A4 is still possible and it's
played but it's no longer a skewer this
is such a weird configuration of pieces
when you ever see a Queen Bishop battery
on the A3 f8 diagonal it's just not not
usual but Rook E8 was just played as a
very natural move defending the pawn and
unfortunately for white you can't bring
the second Rook to D1 you'd love to do
that Knight B5 is maybe more appealing
but E7 E5 not really a huge threat
because as soon as black pushes that
pawn then the Knight goes to B5 and if
you don't capture it it goes into D6 so
I feel like uh the move E5 is not
actually scary which gives white a turn
to find an alternative to a move like
Knight B5 yeah you're absolutely right I
just think Maxime is defending that pawn
because Queen takes C7 actually was a
threat on the previous move Magnus plays
it safe with Rook C1 and
Maxine he sees something in this
position he just drives the pawn all the
way down to E4 reopening his bishop and
he could even move it to E3 under the
right set of circumstances but I
wouldn't do it immediately Robert
because that would reopen White's light
squared Bishop Bishop C5 right cutting
off the queen from that Knight oh you
can't play a six the Knight is hanging
yeah and you either have to move the
Knight or attack this bishop on C5 he
goes rookie to do just that and okay
white is not worse here
and I feel like again Magnus he just
does it so effortlessly he's down 90
seconds on the clock he's getting pushed
around and in the span of three moves
he's totally equalized the game again
you know you say equal but there's a
Pawn on F7 so in positions with Bishops
of opsa color and Brooks on the board
you look for potential targets that F7
Pawn if white could play E3 Bishop F1
Bishop C4 now we're talking about white
playing for a win however with the trade
about to happen Rook takes B7 that
Bishop it takes too long to get around
blocking like King f8 and rookie seven I
think Magnus is playing for a win though
just seeing that last movie three if you
wanted to draw you would have grabbed B7
he wants to get this bishop around to C4
it's not efficient but if it lands on C4
and if you tie down black stroke you
won't even care if you're down a Pawn on
the queen side he's not going to be down
upon he grabs it but mvl needs to play
cautiously for a couple moves here to
secure the draw and I think he's doing
just that yeah he defends the pawn on B5
preemptively does Rook F5 which is even
one to follow oh I don't I don't like H5
I thought mdl should have put his rookie
on C5 what's he doing
Rook C1 Rook C2 and Bishop E1 maybe but
that was just very artificial oh Rook C1
Rook C2 there's Bishop A4 the bishop on
B4 is loose there no what is Maxime
doing
oh no
he's seven or Bishop E8 oh my gosh
what's this same idea to go to Bishop B3
it's still drawable Rook C7 is Bishop
takes E3 so you have to be very careful
about that great call and Magnus just
solidifies the pawn structure look at
Black's light Square pawns on the king
side all of them can be picked off under
the right set of circumstances with a
well-timed bishop F7 he plays it
immediately it should be eight oh no
Rook C6 is just done
goodbye one Bang Bang
yeah Bishop F7 rookie six is a mate
threat oh that is a heartbreaker what
can you possibly do against this guy
right like every single game there's a
moment where like okay Maxine's doing
well he's clawing back it's equal and
then in like three normal looking moves
he's lost
it's crazy
I'm speechless and you called it in the
previous game once they got into the end
game I assumed I made the mistake of
assuming that an equal end game is a
draw but an equal end game in the hands
of Magnus Carlson is basically a win
every time I told you that F7 Pawn Yeah
when there's a fixed Target and it
wasn't fixed it went to F5 but then G6
became a fixed Target that is the
problem look at this game here Magnus
throwing his A5 Pawn to A4 he's just
using a spatial Edge on the queen side
to counteract the fact that his Center
is a bit flimsy
and he's got to decide how to defend the
E5 Pawn he does so with Knight bd7 now
of course he has to solve the problem of
his bishop and mvl quickly trying to
step on the gas pedal and put pressure
on his center before blacks completed
his development but see
I feel like I've seen this position
before
can I see five was that what you
expected D6 maybe should be considered
for MBO
I feel like like some kind of farusha
game was in his exact position before C5
but that's not a hero there Knight comes
up to E4 is D6 a threat when you have a
pawn that can push the sixth rank you
should always consider it opens up the
bishop on A2 which is slicing across the
board that can actually be quite scary
for black to deal with the bishop is
sniping at F7 the Knight can jump into
G5 and White's position is going to
start to breathe if Magnus allows this
to happen so Queen E7 comes to mind
hitting the Knight and protecting D6 but
I'm just really worried for Black's
position maybe Rook A8 to A6 I feel like
that's a Magnus type of move I was about
to recommend that I was just waiting for
you thought of it I mean The Rook lift
looks very promising he goes Knight F6
trying to trade off what might be an
opposing Knight if you go into Knight to
D6 and take the bishop on C8 that Bishop
wasn't developed anyway not going
anywhere and unfortunately if you're
Knights on D6 you can't push your Pawn
to D6 so 96. oh wait I don't believe in
this because black could even first of
all black to play Queen B6 and I feel
like that night is a paper Tiger yep
second of all black and play Queen B6
and third of all Magnus played Queen B6
yep know that first second third does
check out Knight takes D5 is now kind of
a threat
what's the guy doing on E6
well I think we should show everybody
what the point was that if that Knight
were captured on E6 and if it's captured
next move then after d takes E6 you're
attacking the Knight and threatening E7
with check because the bishop on A2 is a
long range sniper hitting the King on G8
and in this case winning the queen in
the other case winning the Knight back
with interest back we go to the live
board mvl's just chilling on E6 but now
the Knight has become a massive
liability and it can actually already be
captured under the right set of
circumstances it's trapped it can go to
d8 oh my congratulations Knight to the
other side not get you a queen and
Knight d896 the D5 Pawn is hanging in
many of these positions as well so uh
you may be able to run away for a bit
but I don't think it's going to be good
and Magnus is finally ready to bring his
Bishop into the action I think Bishop B7
basically ends the game mvl is losing
his heart here it's C4 also no C4 drops
D4 so and it should be seven just drop
E5 so Bishop A6 looks quite promising
here's Knight B6 good move also good
nice three takes D5 and that's it or
just F takes e66 right you've there's no
more night hanging on D7
yeah take the Knight and go Queen E7
or C4 oh even better
just I mean heartless and he wins by
another game he is up by six points
Dania and that was a dominant display
right out of the gates be still my
Beating Heart just in the blink of an
eye this could have been down to three
it could have been down to two if nvl
had capitalized on his opportunities but
we talk about it all the time you never
know when you're gonna get another
opportunity against Magnus so you when
you miss one after the other it's only a
matter of time before Carlson turns it
on wait wait was there a knight C5 there
am I missing something
I don't think you are I think
Bishop E6 is the move against Knight B5
but not against Knight B3
that was so bizarre wait it was nice if
I'm just like much better for what yeah
that was really weird Bishop E6 and then
back to C8
strange even down here Knight C5 a
second time hitting the bishop and the
pawn on B7 all at once and then Queen B3
in response to Bishop why why is Magnus
allergic to this move well maybe he's
gonna sneeze and then play it but Knight
C5 I mean it looks really good you're
just hitting two pieces at once I'm
gonna give him a Benadryl if it doesn't
play it and he does
okay you take on B7 your knight
apparently gets trapped but now it
doesn't just goes back to C5 I guess MPL
is saying he gets a lot of Peace
activity with Knight C6 to D4 creating
some tension in White's position but uh
honest upon
is a pawn I guess it's somewhat E5 and
Rook B8 but the problem is the Knight on
C6 is also loose and if it ever moves
the bishop on G2 protects that Knight on
B7 there's an anti-positional movie for
here but it drives the black Bishop back
and perhaps that Knight C5 comes with
Tempo I don't know exactly how Magnus
should handle this
A3 little moves big consequences Rook C1
there could be a bishop takes C3 and
Knight takes A3 up in the air
true
that is there an alternative though and
by the way maximum is a full three
minute so either he's tilting or he's in
some kind of preparation
or both
[Laughter]
yeah that's true that's the worst case
scenario
yeah Bishop C3 Knight A3 comes to mind
but again always hard to part ways with
your grunfeld Bishop
yeah white would just be better an
unopposed Bishop pair
oh and a better end game and magnus's
hands is almost a sure Victory
especially when he's playing with this
confidence and this level of Verve that
was a three minute way of doing it yeah
ba3 Bishop takes C3 Rook C1 two pieces
in a row but the Knight comes into D4
and that's actually white who is in some
trouble there so a very very good move
from Maxime there yeah the pawn is
overloaded this is a standard
overloading tactic now Bishop takes C6
Rook C6 Knight D5 speaking of
overloading is a double attack so Bishop
takes C6 vaccine will have to strike on
C3 first
move orders very important in chess so
Bishop takes Knight is about to happen
no other choice Bishop D7 I think is a
bailout move if Carlson wants to draw
which I think he does want
so how Josh is this that's always the
question when Magnus is playing Bishop
D7 Rook D7 Bishop takes B2 Rook takes E7
now white has an extra Pawn from the e
to the H file black has the past a pawn
oh my gosh gosh I just never say the
word draw when Magnus is playing I know
every time I say okay bail out draw the
position is dead before you know it
Magnus Carlson pulls off uh what he
managed to pull off in uh the game The
Last white game he played
what is Maxine thinking about he finally
does take on D7 and he has to take on B2
so he gets here Rook E8 is one
possibility let's just trade off the
Rooks because the E2 Pawn is loose
behind it
um I don't think there's anything to
fear at least not yet if you're Maxim
the game is Max seemingly heading for a
drop but you just never know
oh boy the first of the day yeah it's
true you're first and hopefully your
last
my feelings are hurt what can I say we
still have to do the finals so you need
to be careful in how you choose your
words Magnus giving up E2 is there like
a rook da Bishop D6 type of thing or
maybe he wanted Bishop to H6 I'm not
totally sure but whatever it was and
Bill didn't like it
and I guess he's Paving the way for a7a5
right so if you push E3 maybe A5 then I
can come back to C5 for white to stop
the a pawn but those pieces are pretty
well placed for black weirdly the bishop
is restraining The Rook like Rook D4 and
Rook C1 are both moves you'd want to
play through dislodge the Knight you
can't play either of them and look at
the clock mvl's fast play has reaped its
rewards he's up 90 seconds and he's got
a chance here and all it would take is
one win to give him the confidence he
needs I think to be super competitive in
these last nine minutes yeah there's a
problem here for black A5 is met by Rook
C7 hitting that Knight away from C4 so
Knight B6 first and if Rook C7 there's
Knight D5 so The Rook comes back to T2
uh oh you know why I actually kind of
like White's chances here is the safe
for the king but now the Bishops are off
I there's nothing major
I feel like it's so easy when you're
tilted it's very easy to miss a fork I
know that's a weirdly specific statement
but you're just let like Rook C7 right
98 check so easy to miss that would be
tragic but even Knight B5 you have to go
Knight C8 that's such an ugly defensive
move exactly exactly
oh
okay
oh my God but King GA blunders Knight F6
as well he has to go to h8 wow you
called it King safety Magnus is gonna
drive the pawn up to G5 and create
mating possibilities on the eighth rank
so Knight D5 is possible there he is H4
no
he's gonna move his Knight around a bit
now he gets four G5
and he might even sack E3
oh my God and Rook HQ oh my God he could
get mated there yeah no this is actually
a very real Rook D2 Rook d8 Rook G8
don't mind if I do my lands rookie two
there's Knight D6
he cements the Knight with Brook to A6
interesting move yeah
if Knight B6 Back The Rook probably
about to retreat at someone but Knight
B6 King G2 that way you go Rook A1 Rook
H1 and so on and kg2 still looks good F4
though by Magnus he's not gonna give up
no no this is really bad for black oh my
gosh
as well now the night has to go back to
B6 and NBL suddenly hanging by a threat
and you called it I think he's gonna go
E4 he didn't though Knight D7 there's
Rook C7 you it's still good almost zooks
vong by NBL though oh then King f8 oh my
gosh just like tempo for Tempo at this
point
I'm pushing that e-pawn if I'm Magnus
where is he going Knight D6 where no
Knight B5 uh if King E7 there's Knights
cable the king d That's oh that's you
could take on A7 there yeah Knight A7 is
probably in trouble but he can torture
that for another 10 minutes yeah but
Magnus knows that that's maybe too easy
of a draw for maxim that's why he didn't
oh Knight seat I guess there's a trade
on scene my bad but I was just trying to
think if you take on A7 here it might be
too easy of a draw but there's nothing
better again he's playing the match
right he's up six points he gets a
risk-free position that he can torture
out for another minute or two ensure
that the next game is the last game it's
hard to refuse this I also feel like
Magnus is just so tricky like he knows
the little tricks here how to prolong
the game how to make black just have to
defend an extra move E4
yeah he's gonna milk this out and then
play E4 when there are no other
opportunities left such as right now oh
it's very smart to do that I think we
should add that is really smart because
even though Magnus has a huge lead
things get crazy and bullet and it's
easy to tilt so you might as well just
keep this lead and try to run down the
clock and Magnus is actually playing for
when he's not just making random moves I
think he's going to play E4 at some
point it is
I don't like to say dead draw it is a
pretty easy draw if you don't tilt for
maxim standpoint and yeah he's
essentially ensured now that the next
game is going to be the last time for A4
nope still doesn't play it there it is
stop it stop it no no no no no
go away go away oh gosh that was crazy
is that gonna be another Reddit viral
clip on Reddit oh man man that was crazy
[Laughter]
yeah this end game continues it should
be a drug just want to give a shout out
to over 50 000 people watching across
twitch and YouTube hakara with the chat
he is a finalist in the speeches
Championship he is likely going to face
off against Magnus Carlsen shout out to
Hikaru who had a great performance
yesterday to beat nihal sarin who gave
him all he can handle but right now we
are in the end game here if that can get
to G7 if only Eric H1 come on Maxine
draw and it's a draw
and Magnus took another minute and a
half off the clock once again ensuring
that this is most likely going to be the
last game of the three plus one segment
I'm not gonna State the obvious this is
a must win for Maxime I mean you called
it the bullet it's crazy there's enough
time for a comeback but Magnus is not
about to give away seven games in a row
like he's just not gonna do that I I
don't think that's humanly possible for
anybody against Magnus Carlson and we're
getting this position again I don't
think Maxime is going to allow night
Rook takes F3 at any point because that
was a very bad mistake by him and it
gave black all the fun so he's thinking
here about how to continue but Queen E2
is often by Knight H5 to F4 anyway
and I feel like this is the kind of
position that's uh good to play In
classical because you have a lot of time
to handle the pressure on the king side
and you're probably slightly better
objectively in a Blitz game though it's
so easy to miss a tactic like Knight
takes C4 like Knight H5 Knight F4 check
so I think a good practical decision for
Magnus to go for this structure what was
that million move game in the Cannons
was it like ferrugia against rajabov
that was in a game from this position
yeah and I think Borussia did play this
G3 I get a knight on H2 at some point
yeah that game went on forever but I
think it's to your point that In
classical chess you can rearrange your
pieces and try to find the right time to
strike with D4 uh but now in Blitz Rook
F7 Rook f8 these so obvious for black
and not necessarily easy to meet for
white and Knight H2 is a very prudent
move it gets the Queens off the board
but now in Comes the Night stopping D4
and to prepare D4 you might have to play
this very ugly move F3 he just played it
and he really really wants to get D4 in
which I think is make makes some sense
you can play for D5 to carve out the
square for his Knight on E3 but that
undoubles Black's pawns and the position
remains in the balance it's a level game
right now but Magnus throughout the day
how many times have we seen as a pawn
get to A4
yeah and as the h-bond get to H5 I mean
he just loves pushing his Corner pawns
and carving out space and if you're
looking to improve your end games you're
watching the greatest end game player in
history in his element has he lost a
single end game today how many games has
he even lost overall right I think he
only lost game three of this match oh my
gosh I mean this is insane
he was down a piece a full peace in one
of these games the three plus one time
segment but he did not lose and right
now with the black pieces well he's
doing well on the clock he's doing well
on the board the problem though is what
is Black's idea maybe black can just sit
and wait for white to try to strike but
at some moment E4 to E5 looks a bit
uncomfortable for black to deal with
because you don't want to take any five
and give yourself an isolated pawn and
if you play D5 well then a knight goes
to D4 you carve out that square for your
uh for yourself so that's something
that's a good point and I think that's
why partially Magnus played Knight C7
maybe he's preparing E5 although you
pointed out that that weakens D5 so in a
weird way White's position might be
practically easier to handle I'm also
thinking of getting a knight to B5
another Pawn structure transformation
and this one also looks like it's in
White's favor yeah the C7 Pawn that's a
bit of a Target but the Rook comes up to
A5 it will slide to B5 that keeps the
Rook on E2 on us it needs to stay on
that second rank to keep the B2 Pawn
safe but it's not out of the question
the white at some point just shuffles
the road up to the same line and goes
after Black's Pawns yeah that Rook Hips
Don't Lie Rooks on E2 don't lie and
Carlson's end gameplay doesn't lie
either will he play D5 you gotta watch
for F4 F5 a well-timed F5 could shatter
the pawn structure the pawn 96 is a
major liability here and that's why
Carlson is investing quite a bit of time
maybe Rook F7 to E7 just to keep the
tension and keep the D5 score available
for the Knight that also makes a good
deal of sense here yeah the rookie seven
maybe there's a shop on D6 and then
white plays D5 but it seems the
evaluation bar approves of your line
that Magnus has played here the king for
black can come to F7 the Kings need to
be involved in the end game it can be
used as a weapon or as a defensive piece
but it does not need to be safeguarded
in the corner so a good move by Magnus
shuffling The Rook out of the king's
path and I think it's a big moment for
Maxine whether or not he could play for
a win from here oh absolutely and he has
to decide between e takes D6 and a move
that keeps the tension he plays
concretely going for your idea and King
F7 I think is magnus's response there's
also E5
but at this point no Knight T4 runs into
Rook takes D5
and that's an important resource
otherwise that night is in the game
careful though careful don't get quite
this resurgent deep on oh goodness and
then a rook C2 as well
I think that's what he should do oh King
E4 coming but not anymore Rook before
check King F5 you could get checkmated
there I seem as close to just winning
this game outright King E4 and Rook D5 I
think is the path forward oh that's
really important if the Black Ink gets
the E6 black is better so exactly four
king of seven Rook D5 that is a great
suggestion by you and the oh my gosh I
believe it keeps white ahead and white
might be winning there the computer
gives an absolutely wild line if Magnus
finds this I'm going to leave my chair
let me show this really quickly on the
analysis board King F7 Rook D5
apparently the only move is Rook B6 King
takes C5 and now Rook Rook E7 E7 check
and a temporary sacrifice to get this
Pawn in a vulnerable square and somehow
black is close to holding a draw here
this might still be winning after rookie
five but let's settle in and watch wow
that is what a recessive variation and
he has just made the move Rook d8 it
looks like so we're not going to see uh
that King F7 move but that was a nuts
line that you know you can't blame
magnets for missing and even if he found
it as we're just saying the king and
pawn and game might have been lost
anyway so Rook F2 from mag imagine
excuse me cutting the king off Rook B6
here intending King takes E5 rookie
eight check with a similar type of idea
if the King goes to the D file Rook
takes D6 and Rook d8 picks up the Rook
the problem is that you don't have to
play okay goes rookie yay but now Rook
D5 he wants a check on B before Magnus
holding his own somehow maybe it's time
for D7 what do you think there's also
something to be said for A3 just to take
away that check on B rate move that's
such a mature move and come back move
he's just saying you are not going to
check me so when I go Rook D5 you are
you're gonna have to move your Rook
elsewhere and then I'll play D7 I'll go
King takes E5 and I should be able to
scoop up the pawn and then with it the
game on the flip side he does give like
the B3 Square maybe The Rook should use
that square as an anchor point and
prepare to give checks from behind once
the white king
capture Z5 but I agree this is should be
a moot point and white should win with a
couple more accurate moves I think you
might also be onto something though Rook
take this Rook G5 check
so yeah he goes to H4 he went A3 and now
he goes to H4 he's just taking away
these squares on the night files
brilliant endgame technique for Maxine
versus no checks against my king he says
and now Rook D6 King E6 can you sing E6
beautiful and Magnus still trying he's
trying to give checks from behind to
drag the king away and if you go rookie
to Robert you let Black's King in look
at this H5 Zoo make a move he does don't
play King D5 Rook 67 check that'll be a
blunder and now white didn't have any
more pawn moves left but he has plenty
of Roku moves on the D file and now
black is collapsing I think that's it
because Rook B6 remember Rook C2
something like King D6 now moving yep
and that's that and Magnus Carlson loses
on the board on time but he still has a
five point lead at this moment Maxine
vasilograph leaves his chair Donya that
was impressive by Maxime in this game it
was and Magnus is not going to be happy
I really think that if Magnus had won
this game a seven point lead would have
pretty much ended the match because you
might not even have time for seven games
considering how long games between these
players tend to last a five-point lead
is surmountable you think about it you
win one or two games only we're talking
about a three-point lead so listen mvl
he's got to take the positive out of
this he won the last game of the segment
he has just a little bit of momentum but
let's be real it's gonna take an
absolute Miracle but we've seen all
sorts of Miracles in our time
commentating the SEC through the years
we certainly have what Magnus Carlson he
doesn't fall victim to those Miracles he
creates them we'll see if Maxine Russia
lagrav can keep winning he just won that
final game with this portion three
minute plus one second immigrant remains
to be seen what happens in bullet but we
will find out after this short break
here at the speed Chess Championship
semi-final match between Magnus Carlson
the world champion and Maxine Buster
legrov in World Blitz champion
thank you
[Music]
now you can use gifts from the biggest
chest stars on all your favorite
platforms just search chess.com and your
favorite chess star on Discord Twitter
WhatsApp and more to find hundreds of
gifts from chess.com's biggest
broadcasts and events nepo Donya Bobby
Anna's and even me Danny try it today
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
on screen he did win the final game of
the three minute plus one second
increment time control he'll need more
from where that came from and Magnus
Carlsen the other hand with this big
lead Dania he should feel right at home
is he seemed comfortable all match he's
been leaning back in his chair he just
seems comfortable as comfortable can be
he is in a state of flow and he has been
for the entirety of the SCC but mvl he
needs something to Crazy something crazy
to happen in this half hour
he needs his pieces to flow I mean he
has been playing quite well but there
have been moments where he's let his
advantages slip he just doesn't maximize
the pressure that he's had and here we
see another English maximize I say I see
who's criticizing my puns but here we go
he needs to start early he needs to win
with both colors and most importantly
just needs to get double edged positions
and he needs to win some time scramble
something he struggled with all match
long Carlson Banco Gambit style he wants
to bring the hammer down early in the
bullet segment I think this is a good
double edged position that you were
calling for for Maxime with the black
pieces he's up a pawn right now D4 is
loses pressure down the B file to B7 as
well and well can you keep this phone
that's the big question Maxim going
after him with D3 now he's got an anchor
point on C2 for his Knight but you don't
want to go Knight C2 too early because
the Rook does have the A2 Square the
Bishops are traded black is making
progress might seem better here in the
early going of game one I think Magnus
wants like a bishop A3 take this Knight
go for the D oh okay that's a nasty
little chick you can't castle that's the
good news for Magnus the king cannot get
to G8 just yet Carlson could have traded
everything on D7 when the pawn back on
G7 but Maxine would have had that
massive passer on okay 97 Queen B4 93
oh he just wins the pawn deck yeah no
more problems Big Pawn
and queen B5 look at that move he didn't
want to trade off things in the a file
he wants to win a pawn here as white
knight takes before does get him a pawn
his foot off the gas pedal again but
still black has some concrete chances
whites King definitely doesn't feel
comfortable here even with only a couple
pieces remaining and Magnus he's sitting
at the he plays D4 to stop that 95
allows the queen this has to be better
for black with the outside okay two
infiltrating the Knight ensconces itself
on B3 but it's chased away immediately
Rook D1 though this is a big moment I
think for Magnus he needs to get some
activity for his piece and get behind
that past spawn agreed completely and
Maxime keeps the tension with H5
Magnus
no but now it's a draw Knight takes C5
it's a swap of everything yeah and then
at the end you can get your Rook around
to B8 which I think is really important
don't go Rook B1 and allow white black
skin to make its way to the queen side
that's right Rook B6 cut off the king
yeah Rook B6 is a nice movie was Rook B7
and C6 if you ever take on C6 you lose
B4 otherwise the king can't get in and
this is a draw but why do you accept it
why would Magnus make it drop Play 50
moves and this is that we signing all
star and losing an end game like this
yesterday because he got impatient milk
a minute milk two minutes off the clock
and you might not even allow enough time
for five more games to be played and be
Unapologetic about it right I know that
in a normal game they would have agreed
to a draw already but this isn't normal
this is a speed Chess Championship and
you want to get that time off the
overall match clock
as we saw yesterday you can lose this
end game you get impatient you pre-move
Rook B3 and that's all it takes but
Maxine's gonna hold this together
but not before 45 more seconds go off
the match clock I feel like there's a
moment when we're defeating with like
King F7 King G6 where magazines try like
a rook h8 and if King F7 is the pre-move
you take on H5 you know what I mean yeah
those are those moments where people
blunder well that and you can offer a
rook trade at the right moment because
then any pre-move on the third rank
would have plundered The Rook in any
case we get a repetition Magnus got some
more time off the clock and a Four
Knights Scotch essayed by Maxime he
needs to start winning right now well
he's a better Pawn structure that's for
sure White's Pawns in touch with one
another on the queen side black with the
isolated pawns but look at the
development for black all three minor
pieces are out White's Queen side
undeveloped and you can play Rook B8
there is Rook D1 then there's C6 to
protect that 995 I think black is steady
right now like a study everything is
solid he can play C6 immediately and he
does just to remove the headache of the
Knight being undefended and now move the
queen away from the pin maybe Queen B6
looks compact looks comfortable for
Magnus this is a good bullet position
Bishop F6 I think completely neutralizes
whatever Edge white might have had a
little bit earlier and you can just take
on D5 if white starts taking everything
there are back rank problems I don't
think yeah take on D5 right here with
the queen oh this is bad Robert this is
not the way to do magnets
Bishop F6 played similar idea
D4 your Rook on A1 thankfully is no
longer under attack but you just push
that deep on up the board
I mean this is just too too simple of a
position which is made on E1 he couldn't
take it he's lost a pawn and mvl
desperately trying to create counter
play but it's too late
H6 that's his idea
actually it's not so simple for black to
stop G5 maybe you can even consider the
move G6 but then that walks into Bishop
to D6 that's not what you want maybe
bishop d8 B6 like just reroute the
bishop to a better diagonal you reruns
the queen and stops G5 good move I
really like that choice
gosh and Magnus puts his Queen on the
perfect square how does he always find
these squares for his pieces it's
honestly crazy yeah you can play rookie
eight everything is safe and sound G5
out of the question H4 you just drop the
H Pawn so where's that Rook going I
don't really see anywhere that
threatening and he pushes
I know where the pawn is going Queen d51
B3 is hanging actually why why trade
Queens
oh because D.A was defended oh my gosh
and now he's down two pawns and he's got
absolutely nothing to show up Queen D5
again is a threat
desperately desperately creating threats
take it and no okay
that didn't work that didn't work take
it Bush I know what you meant
and Neil's still trying a little
something against that black king but
not for long neck come on come on
66 oh
h
no I was just keeping the status quo
milking some time if he knows he's gonna
win this game he knows it's a matter of
time I love what you were saying there
because that's how it must feel playing
Magnus uh no it may no like that's a
nope exactly what happens A6 such a
Magnus move I'm waiting
Brook C6 Queen D5 he gets the queen's up
but White's not losing this anymore
yeah but it's kind of a moot point
because he got so much time off the
clock I think it's like that game where
he's sack The Exchange on F3 he's not
gonna be happy but he just took another
five minutes off the match [ __ ]
preserved his lead and a great way to
force the draw if your Magnus yeah the
watch out for F5 F6 he oh he checks
himself getting some space for his king
that's really important here and if
Magnus can keep this game going he can
waste another couple minutes off the
mesh Cloud Hikaru would find a way to
just it's like get all the meat off the
bone every little sliver of chicken
chicken winner winner chicken dinner
oh this is the perfect bracket
okay it's a draw so we still have a five
point lead for Magnus Carlson we're
getting back to Knight F3 G3 systems and
for Maxine's eyes I just can't quite win
a game and that's why he's getting into
offbeat openings and this is actually
quite a popular line you can see why
playing D3 and then pushing D4 and
that's a common technique because the
Knight on C6 is quite misplaced in this
type of position and that is why because
D5 comes with Tempo crunch in white
steps on black center with his Boot and
Carlson with the slight opening
Advantage here yeah Knight G5 or 94 hits
the bishop and the B7 Pawn but C4 is
under attack that's why Magnus first
plays B3 94 is an exchange sacrifice
Knight takes E4 Bishop takes A1 there's
all sorts of tactics in the air there
and apparently some tags are being
missed maybe it's Knight D4 just go
after the Beast yeah and the bishop
might have had to drop back to C8 a
super awkward Square Carlson's just
gonna go Rook 81. it's such an easy
position to handle a knight D5 rubber
you like to point these ideas out could
come at a very inconvenient moment for
black leading to more trades and a
favorable transformation for white
I just love these little moves like A3
because Knight B4 could have been a
follow-up if you played Knight D5 too
soon now the C7 Pawn is a target uh the
E6 square is white for the taking the
Knight on e4 well can be captured at any
moment and Rook C1 things of that nature
are not going to be pleasant for black
to meet
when Magnus is determined to play with
an abundance of caution there's just
nothing you can play to unbalance the
position he's going to keep it under
control you can play The Dutch you can
play whatever you want yeah Knight F5
there what a pawn
MPL is actually making some progress but
he's not gonna get h4m
look at this cocoon E3 G3 you're not
getting F4 and I just take it and you're
not only Force hanging to boot and
there's no sacks on G3 to worry about
look at mags improving his pieces Bishop
takes E4 would force takes E4 but you do
not want to give up those light squares
you can play Knight takes F5 here the
downside is that then you reopen the
conversation of H4 maybe Magnus just
wants to keep the status quo he does and
he attacks H5 Mike see his kingside
pawns can hardly be defended maybe Queen
G5 and a queen F3
ugly Rook C1 Queen F4 offer man and
that's exactly what he does very
magnus-like Rook C1 the C7 Pawn let's
not forget about that week that was the
reason he played Knight T5 in the first
place great call
just you can go for it now right Rook C1
and he might bring his Rook to C4 and
just take on e4
and Robert playing on both sides of the
board all of these top GMS do that so
well 93 Queen Knight H3 what a tactic
that is an amazing stuff from Maxine
Russia and Magnus I think he's laughing
a little bit but he's chuckling because
he's impressed not because he's happy
and guess what Maxine's gonna win this
game he's gonna have to win it fast and
it's suddenly a four point match I mean
this is not over and another amazing
move Knight G4 Queen D4 checkbox out
Queen A1 mate rookie one mate too many
threats singing his Praises but Maxime
stays tactically alert he doesn't give
up hope and he's up a full Rook but
obviously Magnus ain't resigning until
uh the fat lady sings in a full 20
minutes on the match clock magnets can't
move look at his his King it cannot get
off the first rank Rook back with check
just move your king now if you're black
you can do whatever you want take it
Maxine take and go Knight E3 just clear
clear the Shrubbery and promote a pawn
and win he's just saying yeah and Max is
going to lose on time or just give up
all his pieces he is wasting as much
match clock as possible and it's crazy
that Maxime has outplayed him I would
say in many games in Smash God Maxine is
taking you so long to win this Carlson
is going to build up another 20 seconds
and take it off the clock
stop the move before Checkmate you know
what's hilarious is that top players are
not often accustomed to making the best
moves that avoid Checkmate in two
because they resigned way before that
point but Max did a pretty good job he's
not on the losing side of you know very
often but he prolonged it well into
about 19 minutes barely over 19 minutes
remaining that's Checkmate and Maxime
down to four he has a chance he has a
chance there is time remaining on the
clock and Robert the first step toward
this miracle comeback is so the seeds of
doubt in magnus's mind because when
Magnus is sure that he's gonna win the
guy is totally Unstoppable so bring this
down to three and start giving Magnus
the heebie-jeebies this is a crucial
game and Magnus ain't happy he's not
happy that he lost that previous game
because that was the match right there
if he had won right and he does not want
a close match he wants to flex his
muscles show his might and right now
with the white pieces Maxine has a nice
looking position of course Magna strikes
at D5 and not getting away with it but
yeah this D3 Pawn now is the problem why
didn't why did Maxine take on D5 I don't
know this is looking not that good the
light squares in the queen side or what
are the taking quite practical good
practical decision though he's gonna go
Rook C1 he's going to try to exploit
some of the flimsy squares on Black's
Queen side but Magnus is handling this
very very well 97 95 comes to mind and
he's got just a blockade on the iqp here
it's excellent you want to play D5 and
Knight D4 but after D5 Queen takes D5
he's going for it anyway no this is this
ain't gonna cut it
rookie four there was Knight see through
the fork Magnus though super Alert in
this game yes Queen back to B7 all his
safe and sound and it's extra on a
healthy extra Pawn for black
yeah and the sound of
Carlson's Victory starting to ring in
mbo's ears he needs to pull another
comeback in this game some tactics some
Intrigue but the position Robert is too
symmetrical where is this gonna come
from Magnus just crushing him the bishop
couldn't move the 92 was loose now you
can just take on E3 with either The Rook
or the Knight he goes like this and the
E3 Pawn C4 E4 and he resigns smart
presentation what unfortunately for him
the time is ticking and he may have to
win all the games from here on out if
you're Mexican yeah he absolutely does I
think there is enough time at this point
to get five games started but the way
this match is going
let's be real the one game X team has
won thus far it was a fluke tactic
Magnus ain't giving him any more gifts
in the bullet
the rookie four move was awfully nice
though
absolutely but right now with the black
pieces he's down a pawn it's like a
Scandinavian type of position where are
you ever gonna get that pawn back
um
white can play Queen B3 on demand
Carlson likes to go A4 in these types of
positions
but instead he deploys his bishop and
he's just playing for simplification a
great match strategy given the state of
the match right now Carlson playing with
an abundance of caution no risk and
every second that goes off the clock
right now is golden for MBL Queen B3
forces Bishop takes Knight the pawn to
take back even material nothing to worry
about in White's Camp so if you're
Magnus I think he's fake thinking right
now he's just spending some time
East coasting he's on cruise control
and all he cares about is milking time
off the clock he's more than happy with
the draw
and this is not looking good for Maxime
yeah trades Galore if he doesn't get
that pawn back that would be a shame
Queen be three
and B7 is loose uh-oh Queen B6 maybe is
okay Maxine going for some King side
play he wants to sack the pawn into a
rookie eight I like that approach right
but one not out of the question
completely don't go Queen A6 I don't
know special page two that would be a
sad one using his King for defense love
that move and the problem for black you
shouldn't variously this earlier if like
the queen could sneak into F4 and H2
black would be doing well but you can't
get to F4 because that night
I think that was in the Marshall game
good good reference there Queen E7
rookie one is simple
A3 and rookie one
it goes Knight C3 you can go Queen E2
next if he wants
like right now and if you move the queen
H5 Falls
getting F1 the best engine move Carlson
is just a Carson is freaking machine
he's a little good at chess I don't know
if people know that
it's it's unbelievable how often he
finds engine moves in critical moments
just crazy and now he's gonna go for the
queen trade
he should win this game
yeah and even if he doesn't win the game
it draws good enough if it wastes
another several minutes off the clock
or sure Maxime trying and poking and
prodding and chiseling his way into
White's position winning back a pawn but
he ain't getting more than that and
Carlson Gonna Keep His Pawn advantage
and keep on milking I'm like wondering
if this white king doesn't go to C6 at
some point but now the pawns are all
under attack actually wait me too Queen
B2 whoa who's there he just keeps both
A2 and B2 under attack but now Queen E4
check forces to draw I think I guess
it's a Perpetual Queen H1
but we've seen the same story before
Carlson can take some more time off the
clock he decides to allow the repetition
14 minutes on the match clock and Robert
again he still has a shot but again he's
got to be perfect from now on he needs
to win games and win them quickly and
we're seeing a scotch game we're getting
a Danish Gambit not quite D5 it should
be 594 oh
an old line yes no bad line what is he
it's a bad GF no I play this exact
variation something like this against um
in the blitz stream like Invitational
Blitz event and I got crushed from uh
from this line with white I don't
understand the Zen of this line at all
he's down two pawns and he's getting
mated let's move 13. I play this with
white and it looked like this it was
horrible
yeah I mean
H5 easy play for Magnus and
unfortunately for Maxima does appear
that his SCC run is starting to come to
an end still anything can happen
well
not with Magnus not with Magnus not with
this position I mean Bishop D5 oh F4
wins the bishop
brutal or a or even H4 but F4 closes off
the rest of the diagonal
yeah H4 Bishop E5 Queen G4 the Queens
are coming off that looks terrible one
yeah we're gonna do one Queen G4 again
just trade Queens whoa oh
to avoid the fork and he saw it so
quickly Queen G7 retreating the queen
hitting G2 with mate and no more Knight
B5 tactics
unreal
no just how do you beat a Magnus Carlson
that's this alert that's this sharp
that's this fast that's this merciless
that's this technical
is up to six points and Maxine with his
last gasps here
and Maxine going for all pawns no hope
the Carroll Khan is essayed in this game
and will Maxine play E5 it is a
committal move it unfortunately will
give him an isolated Pawn but at least
breaks in the center and at this point
Donya was still 12 minutes remaining he
has a lot of Chess to be played but it's
not going to matter because when all is
said and all is done Magnus Carlson will
be facing hikaranakamura in the speed
chess championship final
and as we start to draw some conclusions
from this match I really think that
Maxim's best chance for a comeback game
at the start of the three minute portion
You could argue that maybe even in the
bullet if you had won one of these games
if he had brought this lead down to
three which was possible he would have
had a shot but realistically I think the
match got away from him when he missed
those let's say three opportunities in a
row Rook takes C4 Knight D6 ends the
game
yep because another one bites the dust
if Rook C1 you just take back it can't
take on D5 because Bishop C4 oh you
don't even take on E8 you just take Play
Bishop C4 with the queen and if the
queen moves to D7 you come around and
take the bishop mvl's gonna resign this
one brutal
brutal chess from this is 300 rating by
the way Magnus just reached 3300 bullet
he is not toying around all right mvl
you can slow him down now don't let him
get to you know 33 40. I wonder why you
would say that
um I don't know
but the way he's going nobody can stop
him right now no he's uh in good for me
he was shaky if we're being honest at
the end of the three plus one so our
threat three plus one really uh but he
was just masterful in the five plus one
and here in the bullet he also has been
a man on a mission
I'm going to repeat what I said earlier
Robert which is that it's human nature
you go up Five Points thank you for
nothing gospel you relax a little bit
and often you let your opponent back in
the match and we saw that a couple of
times in the SEC Magnus literally does
the polar opposite right he goes up by
four points and then he just rattles off
five games in a row and even now he's
not relaxing he's playing the best
bullet that he's been playing all SEC
long and it comes in a moment when the
match has already been decided yeah it's
pretty nice and we have to sort of freak
out when Maxine cuts the deficit to Four
Points right it's not like it was one it
wasn't even that close uh but there were
moments there where it did seem like
Maxine was right in it unfortunately for
him he couldn't put Magnus away in
critical moments that game in particular
where Magnus simply blundered a piece
and maximum couldn't win that that was
just heartbreaking for him
yeah and and especially when you're
playing the world champion you don't
know how many of those chances you're
gonna get you know you won't get a lot
of them
and there is still money to be
apportioned 50 of the prize fund per
match is divided based on win percentage
so let's see if Maxime
can score a couple more Benjamins with
nine minutes left in the match All About
the Benjamins the problem for white for
maximiers the knights are kind of stuck
with each other the 9d4 moves you lose
B5 they're in E2 moves you're capturing
D4 so F3 played
all sorts of things Knight C5 you're
pointing out I was thinking Knight D2 is
it possible to go to C4
you could do it through D6 but then you
blunder the D5 Pawn good point yeah I
like 92 to C4 and Magnus of course plays
it of course he sees it he sees
everything
he really does see everything Knight C4
and queen E1 and Knight E3 and Knight F1
and Knight G3 and queen H1
and queen H4 mate that's how the game is
gonna end yeah no keep singing to me
that was quite Pleasant so Knight takes
E3 King E3 rookie eight something like
that he says it was rookie at first why
take any risk
and Feingold is chuckling in
satisfaction
somewhere as he watches the match 93 and
another win for Magnus oh yeah the
Knight on D4 is just hanging Knight D1
check things of that sort
there must be some sort of tactic here
maybe even a queen sack but Queen C5 is
a magna-style move
yeah Queen T2 clinical
Knight on D4 moves Knight D1 picks up
the 92 with mate
get out of here another little finale to
this match
Carlson and I think Maxine might be he's
resigning match yeah he has resigned the
match and you are allowed to do that
once you're under 10 minutes remaining
and the match clock you can throw in the
towel say this is not gonna happen and
that is what has occurred Magnus Carlson
moves on this final score is actually
17-9 what a performance from the world
champion the largest lead of the match
comes at the end of the match and a
totally understandable decision for mvl
let's not blame him for even a second
for ending the match Heat he got it
close right he gave Magnus a run for his
money he played great chess but at the
end of the day the failure to deliver on
the opportunities that he had if you
even do it once your chances of
defeating Magnus Carlson diminish
greatly what a match by the world
champion and what an SCC run to the
finals
it's been amazing I mean Magnus Carlson
he's looked borderline Invincible there
were parts of this match where Maxine
was giving him all he could handle so
the final score 79 maybe it feels you
know a little bit lopsided in Max's
favor but Maxime had his moments he
didn't capitalize and that allowed
Magnus to sail through with an eight
point win Dania he's a beast it's been a
treat to watch his games it's been an
honor to call them and the world
champions the greats they make it look
easy I mean he's won these matches by an
average of 12 13 points and he's playing
the leading Blitz players in the world
Maxine may have defeated Magnus two
years ago but Robert I think it's very
it's fair to say this is a completely
different Magnus from even the one that
we saw winning the SCC he's winning
these matches he's just wiping people
off the board in every type of position
it's extremely impressive and well we'll
have the honor of hearing from the man
himself because after this short break
we're bringing Magnus Carlson the world
champion the speeches Champion finalist
and a few just after we return
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and we are honored to be joined by world
champion Magnus Carlson Magnus
congratulations on the match Victory and
my first question for you is well how
did it feel because in the early going
things were pretty neck and neck and
then you were able to pull away
yeah I felt that uh the games were
pretty even all the way so I never felt
like I was sort of pulling away even if
the score was saying so
Magnus you the only SEC match you ever
lost was two mvl when you go into a
match like this do you care about your
head-to-head record against your
opponent and does it give you any
motivation that you had lost a previous
match or is that totally in the past and
you don't really care
yeah this was the certainly I think is
much of this tournament for uh for me
that I mean I didn't feel like uh
I play particularly better than I did
last time but at least I won so that's
better but yeah I really really didn't
want to to listen again
well you say it's the biggest match for
you you're about to play against hikar
Nakamura I think that's the match-up
that all the fans want to see uh you
know we got a feature chat from Ealing
cushy saying are you excited to play
against hikar the finale or do you
literally not care
well I mean at the moment
[Music]
um
I'm a little bit uh you know exhausted
from from this much I haven't really
thought about it but uh
uh no I'm very happy to be in the finals
I mean even though my level was not
great today
hopefully being in a final take some of
that sort of
pressure off or
some of the
feelings of of an ease that I had from
from losing that much against him two
years ago and
hopefully I can play better on uh on
Sunday I mean that's that's what it's
really all about uh
I
I as I said for the first match here so
like all I care about is having a good
performance
today I didn't really do that but
um so I'm not really satisfied but yeah
at least I got one monkey off my back
and
for uh for the final I mean he's very
strong but I have a good track record
against him and I think none of us
showed anything close to our best level
indeed semi-finals so whoever can can
step up for the final will probably have
a good chance
Magnus you just referenced takara's
match against nihal how carefully did
you watch ikara's matches in the SEC
thus far and how would you assess his
overall play in the SEC
uh frankly I don't think he's been
tested much at all
um I mean in the last in the first
to match this that was a bit of a
mismatch and against nehal I thought
both of them played uh below their their
neutral battles so uh I mean it's
basically strength that he still managed
to win and buy quite the comfortable
margin as well but uh
I think he certainly has a level to you
know to Aspire to that he hasn't reached
so far in the in the tournament but
that's that's the case with the with me
and also him to Great to create that
uh like if an opponent has
a great day and one of us has a really
poor diet and the opponent can can win
if we have just a like regular not so
good diet and we usually then regardless
well magnitude seemingly critical of
your play for today what do you think
you need to clean up in order to uh
continue the good form for Sunday's
match
I just had no flow whatsoever just
constantly missing tactics and
that's thinking very clearly so so that
was the thing I mean I could feel it
from game one but this wasn't uh
I mean this wasn't the day that I was
going to uh to play almost perfectly
like against
like against the family so
I I felt earlier that it was kind of it
was going to be a
VA struggle uh it's just yeah it's just
a case of of some sometimes things come
easily some sometimes it's just a slog
and that's it for my time time
expenditure as well
Magnus I hate to ask a question this
cliche but I think chat is going to
revolt if we don't ask you for your pick
in World Cup final and who you're
rooting for
yeah I'm rooting for for France I have
been rooting for them I mean I was
rooting for them all the way last time
and I've been rooting for them this time
as well but
uh I'm not like super excited about the
World Cup in general like I've watched
parts of it but
um not religiously
that's fair enough and another fun
question from Chad this one from PUD and
snack is if this event existed 20 years
ago which GM do you think would win
would it be Kasparov
uh so 20 years ago that's 2002 uh that
is not so easy to say I think our man
would have had a great chance
um but a couple years before public has
far off but um
2002 probably I know I would say
Magnus my final question sort of a
follow-up to that one do you think the
overall level of Blitz displayed at the
top has markedly increased uh throughout
the time that you've been uh a grand
master and Route your chess career
I mean that's uh I mean it does sort of
meta questions are really hard to
to answer because it's
yeah it's it's hard to to to to to
measure when you you factor in all the
opening advancements and so on but no I
don't think for people haven't become
particularly better I think people have
become better at playing online without
increment but that's a very specific
skill
fair enough well thank you so much
Magnus for joining us congratulations
again on your match Victory we look
forward to seeing you in the final
congratulations
okay see it Magnus well there you have
it the world chess champion Magnus
Carlson makes his way through to the
final he takes on Hikaru Nakamura in
that championship match and Dania that's
the matchup everyone has been waiting
for and that's what they get
both of these players have been on a
mission Hikaru has revealed a little bit
of burnout in the SEC he has played a
lot of tournaments over the board online
Fisher random regular chest cgc but let
me tell you who is not going to be burnt
out to be facing Magnus Carlson I think
both of these players Robert are just
excited to be facing the other this is
going to be one of those classic epic
matchups that we reference for years to
come it certainly will be and while
we're excited for that matchup we're all
so excited to make a huge announcement
that just happened because chess.com
wants to thank you all of the members
100 million members reached when the
site was launched in May 2007 it was
just a dream to bring chess to the
global mainstream but today December 16
2022 we are watching the dream become
reality to celebrate 100 million members
chess.com will be hosting a 100 million
member event in February 2023 a 100 hour
long stream here on twitch.tv wow
jam-packed with your favorite chest
streamers Danny wrench contests merch
giveaways and more thank you to all the
players who Inspire so much love for the
game the community that continues to
grow on chess.com and the team at
chess.com for making all of it possible
this is a huge milestone but it's just
the beginning for chess.com and there's
so much more to come and well while we
have a moment here I'm just going to
bring somebody special onto the camera
because they walked in the room no one
else saw it but me but look at this it's
Danny what's up Danny hey man no one
better to read that than you you can't
spell chess without him Robert Hess this
is totally not planned I came by to give
this guy a hug because we're both
leaving I love you all I love the
community I love you can I kiss you on
camera
so much I love everybody this is amazing
great and you guys are crushing it today
see you on Sunday
bye everybody love you oh Eric
oh my God
I can't believe it
I don't even know what to say all right
I feel like embarrassed with my parents
right now you know
the thing for you oh yeah everybody yeah
all right see you man love you yeah
that's amazing yeah I I would not be
able to draw such a thing if I had a
hundred years yeah Danny's Denny's
daughter made that for me so I mean in
all seriousness we are super
appreciative of everybody's support we
have a lot of fun here I mean ever since
Danny and I were commentating in a small
little literally a closet in an office
space where we had many of you still
here who are watching the speeches
Champions past we want to thank you all
for that but Dania today was all about
Magnus Carlson he really showed
excellent skill he was a Critic of
himself but I think that's part of what
makes him such a star champion is that
even when he has great performances he
still hardened himself he still wants to
perform even better
absolutely and before I offer my
thoughts on the topic just wanted to
Echo your sentiment that it is just an
honor to be part of the chest roll right
now this is the not only the biggest
chess boom of all time but I think the
most sustainable this is a chess boom
that is happening not because of a
particular event or a particular player
but because people are genuinely into
the game and they see the game as a
vehicle to improve their lives they see
it as a wholesome hobby they see it as a
way to make friendships and find a new
community and it's just an honor to to
play a very small but hopefully not
insignificant part uh in the machine
that makes chess.com and the Chess World
as a whole run but speaking of machines
Magnus Carlson has been nothing short of
a machine and we saw him again today so
self-critical Robert and again he's not
putting on an act it's not fake modesty
he really demands Perfection from
himself the match against Fabian and
caruana fit even Carlson's strict
definition of perfection and I don't
think he will necessarily need that
level of perfection against Hikaru but
he might have to come close well you
mentioned the friendships made along the
way there also have to be rivalries for
chess to thrive for any sport or
competitive game to thrive and we have
one coming your way this Sunday it is
the championship it is Hikaru Nakamura
against Carlson and people have been
clamoring for this mouth-watering
matchup it is the Epic final I mean this
couldn't have been scripted any better
if you're a chess fan so Donya you said
it that he may not need to be as perfect
as he was against Fabiano but Hikaru has
shown some good stuff Magnus himself
said that he felt like Hikaru hasn't
been tested well he's about to meet the
ultimate test on Sunday in the world
champion listen we promised this match
wasn't scripted agaro Magnus they didn't
have the easiest path to the top but it
was never really in doubt and now both
of them are meeting their match this is
an epic this is a classic this is just
one of those matches for which everyone
cancels their brunch and whether you
stay in bed and watch this on the TV or
you're sitting at your desk and watching
these two Gladiators go after each other
Robert we are in for an amazing match
and again it's just a great privilege to
have courtside seats to what may very
well become one of the most interesting
and Unforgettable matches in online
parentheses online chess history
and everybody is so hyped right now
because what you'll be doing on Sunday
is watching the World Cup I get it but
then right after that you will be able
to watch Hikaru Nakamura ah face off
against the big boss Magnus Carlson
honestly both of them are the biggest
bosses in chess it's not really
surprising that they've made it this far
but we are super excited so Dania I'll
give you some final thoughts before we
wrap up this show
I mean Magnus Carlson's run in the SEC
that's just one of the things that I'm
going to take away that's one of the
things hopefully you're going to tell
your grandkids I was there when Magnus
Carlson beat Fabiano caruana without
losing a game I was there when Magnus
Carlson Beats gukesh by 15 points and is
then super angry at his play I was there
when Magnus Carlson deals yet another
blow to the Frenchman with three names
this match was never in doubt and yet
again Carlson he aims for Perfection
he's never satisfied and can he reach
the Apex of perfection in his last match
or will Hikaru Nakamura continue his
streak of incredible performances and
rise to the occasion there's only one
way to find out and there's only one
time to find out and that is Sunday at 2
pm Eastern that is true great questions
that will only be answered by the
players but while you were there for all
of magus Carlson's triumphs we were both
here with chess.com crossed 100 million
members so I do again want to give such
a shout out to the chess Community we've
I haven't done yet and myself and all of
chess.com we of course love this game it
is a beautiful game full of enriching
tactics blunders everything you could
ask for and more so we are so happy that
you are here with us and please join us
for another party it's going to be
Sunday 11 A.M Pacific Time 2 p.m eastern
time that will be the speed Chess
Championship final the matchup is a card
Nakamura versus Magnus Carlson I'm
Robert Hess that's Daniel nerdinski
we're gonna say goodbye and see you on
Sunday
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign